bien chers amis
je vais vous demander de prendre place
pour que nous puissions commencer à
ouvrir nos travaux
allons-y
vous connaissez la course tique de cette
salle qui est pas forcément optimale
donc
il est important qu'on est le silence de
la salle pour pouvoir démarrer
ça va tout le monde prend place
bien
merci à tous d'avoir répondu présent à
notre invitation avec Bernard
accueillier secrétaire général de notre
mouvement
bonne année à toutes et à tous d'abord
pour vous pour vos proches et puis bonne
année pour notre famille politique et
puis pour notre candidat François Fillon
je voudrais
je voudrais à l'ouverture de ce conseil
national
saluer l'équipe dirigeante de notre
mouvement Bernard Accoyer comme je
l'indiquais en est aujourd'hui le
secrétaire général vous avez
[Applaudissements]
vous avez à ses côtés Isabelle le
Calinet vice-présidente
vous avez Annie Genevard secrétaire
général adjoint
notre trésorier national
[Applaudissements]
Daniel Fasquel c'est rare un trésorier
populaire quand même bon c'est suspect
mon cher Daniel
Jean-François Lamour qui est le nouveau
président de la commission nationale
d'investiture
et puis nous avons souhaité que nous
consacrions ce conseil national vous le
savez une partie de notre heure du jour
et consacrée aux investitures aux
élections législatives et bien nous
avons voulu montrer ce qu'est le nouveau
visage des républicains le visage des
républicains ce sont de jeunes candidats
qui se présentent aux élections
législatives pour défendre nos couleurs
qui sont pour moitié des femmes qui sont
des entrepreneurs qui viennent de la
société civile ils sont ils sont ici je
tiens à les saluer je veux remercier
Christophe Coulon qui est secrétaire
départemental de l'Aisne vice-président
de la Région Hauts-de-France
candidats au législatif dans l'Aisne
je veux remercier Ludovic fagot qui est
candidat aux élections législatives dans
le Doubs dans la deuxième
circonscription il est vice-président du
conseil départemental je veux remercier
à maintes renouffe qui est conseillère
municipal DIF RDJ du Calvados candidate
dans la deuxième circonscription du
Calvados je veux remercier notre ami
candidate dans l'Indre Paulette Picard
ancienne présidente de la Chambre de
commerce et d'industrie de l'Indre
je veux remercier Sarah gentil qui est
candidate en Haute-Vienne
qui est adjointe au maire de Limoges je
veux remercier Georges Schuller qui est
secrétaire départemental des
républicains dans le Bas-Rhin
et je vous salue tous et tout au long de
la matinée vous aurez l'occasion de
découvrir ces nouveaux visages qui vont
porter les couleurs des républicains aux
élections législatives je veux
évidemment saluer le président du Sénat
Gérard Larcher merci à toi d'être
assidu dès le début de nos travaux
je vous saluer tous les amis
parlementaires qui sont ici réunis
nombreux membres de la direction du
parti qui auront l'occasion de
s'exprimer tout au long de la matinée
que de chemin parcourus mes chers amis
depuis notre dernière Conseil national
que de chemin parcourus avec
l'organisation de cette primaire
que je dois dire certains d'entre nous
redoutés peut-être mais qui s'est avéré
un grand succès démocratique et surtout
un grand succès politique
quel succès quand on a vu je me souviens
là on entendait dire les Français ne
s'intéressent plus à la politique 8
millions de téléspectateurs pendant nos
débats 4 millions de participants à
notre primaire une qualité de débat je
dois dire assez remarquable qui a montré
que notre famille politique était mature
elle était capable de se projeter dans
le 21ème siècle un monde où on est
capable d'assumer des idées où on est
capable de débattre je pense qu'avec ces
primaires la droite française a sans
doute fait un bon de 20 ans en avant et
bien cela mes chers amis ça n'aurait pas
été possible sans vous bien sûr il y a
eu une organisation remarquable avec
Thierry Soler que je tiens à saluer avec
Anne Levade qui a présidé la Haute
Autorité mais les chevilles ouvrières de
la primaire les 80 000 petites mains qui
ont organisé les bureaux de vote qui ont
fait les assesseurs qui ont réglé les
petits détails qui en ont fait une
machine de guerre et bien ça a d'abord
été les cadres les acteurs les militants
des républicains ceux d'entre vous en
particulier qui sont représentés au
Conseil national je tenais à vous en
remercier et à vous en féliciter
les résultats de cette primaire sont
indiscutables François Fillon a remporté
un immense succès clair net et notre
devoir mes chers amis à nous le
Parlement du parti qui représente toutes
les sensibilités qui représentent la
diversité du parti c'est de nous
rassembler derrière lui et c'est de le
faire gagner au mois de mai
personne
personne ne vous demandera de renier vos
engagements et vos fidélités à commencer
par François Fillon lui-même simplement
tout le monde va vous demander
maintenant de vous rassembler derrière
notre candidat derrière François Fillon
je vous le disais nous avons montré un
beau visage avec cette primaire nous
avons montré des débats de qualité ça a
été possible bien sûr grâce à notre
vainqueur par son programme audacieux
par le succès très net qui l'a remporté
mais ça a été aussi possible grâce aux
autres candidats permettez-moi de saluer
ici ce matin tout d'abord Nicolas
Sarkozy
je pense
il a été
notre président de la République
il a été le président de notre famille
politique
il a redressé dans notre mouvement je
pense que le CLIN d'œil chaleureux que
vous lui adresserez lui fera du bien
je veux
merci pour lui
je voudrais saluer à la Juppé
Alain Juppé restera comme un grand homme
d'État
auquel notre famille doit beaucoup
je veux le remercier pour sa campagne
pour le message qu'il a porté tout au
long de ses débats et puis je veux
évidemment remercier les quatre autres
candidats Nathalie Kosciusko-Morizet
Bruno Le Maire
Jean-Frédéric Poisson
Jean-François Copé qui ont montré que la
nouvelle génération des républicains
elle était là elle était talentueuse
elle était capable de débattre et de
servir le pays voilà mes chers amis où
nous en sommes en ce début de l'année
2017 nous avons notre candidat nous
aurons tout à l'heure nos candidats aux
élections législatives et bien
maintenant il va nous falloir amplifier
la dynamique il va nous falloir être les
ambassadeurs de notre candidat François
Fillon il va falloir exprimer bien sûr
les différentes sensibilités mais il va
falloir d'abord montrer que nous sommes
rassemblés montrez que nous représentons
la force de l'alternance et mettre cette
force d'alternance au service de
François Fillon
alors nous allons ouvrir tout de suite
nos travaux par la partie statutaire
vous savez que vous détenez en tant que
membre du Conseil national une
prérogative importante une double
prérogative celle d'abord de voter le
budget de notre mouvement je vais donc
demander à Daniel Fasquelle de venir
nous présenter les contes les contes de
l'année 2016 vous faire voter le budget
2017 et ensuite nous voterons vous
voterez les comptes de notre partie
Daniel c'est à toi
[Applaudissements]
écoutez bonjour à tous ça fait plaisir
de vous retrouver je vous souhaite à mon
tour une très belle année 2017 fait
évidemment deux victoires pour notre
candidat François Fillon à l'élection
présidentielle mais aussi de victoire
pour vous qui seraient nos candidats aux
élections législatives sans oublier bien
évidemment les élections sénatoriales au
mois de septembre alors monsieur le
Président du Conseil national chez cher
Luc merci de me donner la parole je
salue bien évidemment Bernard Accoyer
toute l'équipe dirigeante et puis un
salut spécial également à Gérard Larcher
président du Sénat qui est toujours
présent avec Bruno retaillod et
l'ensemble de mes collègues et amis
parlementaires alors en ce qui concerne
le budget
alors est-ce que ça marche voilà ça y
est quelques mots tout d'abord
évidemment du budget
2016 alors je suis allé un petit temps
des voilà donc vous avez le budget alors
la bonne nouvelle en ce qui concerne le
budget 2016 c'est que nous parvenons à
dégager un excédent budgétaire de neufs
c'est grâce à vous merci
en augmentation de 48% par rapport à
2015 et en augmentation de 141% par
rapport aux prévisions budgétaires 2016
alors comment est-on parvenu à cet
excédent budgétaire vous allez me dire
c'est la primaire je dirais non
puisqu'en fait l'argent de la primaire
va au candidats malheureusement pas aux
parties donc se redressement et cet
accident budgétaire il est dû à vous et
rien qu'à vous alors comment est
intervenu à ce bon résultat et bien tout
d'abord par la maîtrise des dépenses de
fonctionnement et je veux vous remercier
je vous remercier les présidents
départementaux secrétaire départementaux
les trésoriers départementaux mais aussi
toute l'équipe nationale puisque nous
sommes parvenus à poursuivre notre
politique d'économie par la maîtrise des
dépenses de fonctionnement parce que
nous avons fait un million d'euros
d'économies sur le budget de
fonctionnement l'année dernière merci à
vous et le trésorier national
a montré l'exemple puisque depuis deux
ans que je suis trésorié je ne me suis
pas fait rembourser un centime d'euro
voilà parce que je crois que quand on a
une responsabilité il faut savoir
montrer l'exemple
[Applaudissements]
on est parvenus à ce bon résultat grâce
aux maintiens global des recettes dans
un contexte politique compliqué avec des
revenus liés au cotisations des élus
très largement supérieur à ce qui était
prévu au budget et ça c'est un point
vous savez c'est l'un de mes combats que
je mène avec vous j'estime que quand on
est élu des républicains on le doit au
parti on le doit au militants et
naturellement on doit payer ses
cotisations des deux tiers de ces
cotisations revenant d'ailleurs au
fédérations depuis une règle nous avons
voté il y a deux ans donc tous les élus
doivent payer leur cotisation sans
exception on n'y est pas encore mais on
y arrive tout doucement et là vous avez
les résultats concrets dans votre budget
2016 du travail qui a été fait depuis
deux ans puisque en 2014 il avait un
million six seulement de recettes pour
les cotisations des élus et deux ans
après en 2016 nous sommes à 3 millions
d'euros nous avons doublé les recettes
liées au cotisations des élus merci aux
élus qui maintenant remplissent leurs
obligations à l'égard du mouvement
le succès financier de la primaire
a permis alors marginalement 2 millions
de recettes supplémentaires puisque en
trésorier très prudent j'avais prévu 5
millions d'euros de prêts à la primaire
de récupérer 3 millions nous avons
récupéré les 5 millions sur les 5
millions et donc ça nous a fait
demi-heure de recettes supplémentaires
et puis le contexte politique de l'année
a permis aussi de limiter les dépenses
d'actions politiques du parti notamment
en fin d'année de 2,3 millions d'euros
le budget
2016 donc aura permis à la fois
l'organisation de la primaire parce que
nous avons prêté 5 millions d'euros à la
primaire sans lesquels la primaire
n'aurait pas eu lieu le budget 2016 a
permis de poursuivre le désendettement
du mouvement et il a dégagé cette
excédent sur lequel nous pouvons
construire le budget 2017 alors en ce
qui concerne le budget 2017 c'est un
budget qui va se caractériser par la
poursuite des efforts engagés
précédemment la maîtrise des dépenses
c'est la condition sinequanone pour le
redressement du parti avant dans ta mail
redressement de la France la stimulation
des recettes la poursuite du
désendettement du parti et le
financement de l'action politique 2017
en ce qui concerne les dépenses de
fonctionnement je vous propose pour le
budget 2017 des dépenses en baisse par
rapport au budget 2016 non pas que nous
allons faire moins de choses mais tout
simplement nous allons mieux gérer le
parti il y a ce nombre de contrats que
nous allons renégocier que son cours de
renégociation par exemple des
prestations de communication ou les
informatique et ça va nous permettre
donc tout en nous déployant comme nous
sommes déployés en 2016 de faire des
économies dans le budget de
les recettes stimulées avec des dons
nationaux avec un objectif de 7,5
millions d'euros en forte progression
mais c'est l'effet positif attendu de la
victoire de François Fillon à la
primaire et de la victoire de François
Fillon à l'élection présidentielle j'en
suis absolument certain bien évidemment
les adhésions aussi qui ont augmenté des
rôles ressent que ce soit les dons les
adhésions en ce début d'année 2017 on a
vu un bon des adhésions et des dons et
c'est très encourageant les cotisations
des élus bien évidemment qui vont
continuer à rentrer en 2017 alors à ce
sujet j'ai fait un point avec
Jean-François l'amour il faut que les
choses soient claires elles le sont dans
le cadre de nos statuts on ne peut pas
être investi par le parti si on n'est
pas à jour de cotisation
alors les candidats qui vont être
présentés ce matin
le son presque tous
presque tous alors moi je veux que les
choses soient claires et je le dis en
accord avec Bernard collier et avec
Jean-François amour à Luc Chatel ceux
qui ne sont pas encore ils ont jusqu'à
la fin de ce mois 31 janvier pour se
mettre en conformité mais ceux qui
seront investis ce matin qu'ils seront
pas encore formités qui seront pas le
jour de cotisation au 31 janvier 2017 se
verront retirer leur investiture parce
que c'est comme ça au sein des
républicains quand on est investi quand
on a la confiance du parti on doit se
mettre en règle avec le parti
voilà il s'agissant des recettes
stimulées je profite j'en profite pour
refaire passer ce message vous savez que
les choses maintenant sont claires pour
toutes les adhésions et les cotisations
des élus c'est un tiers pour le siège
national et deux tiers pour vous à
chaque fois que vous faites une adhésion
renouvellement au nouvel adhésion à
chaque fois vous faites payer un élu
vous récupérez les deux tiers pour faire
fonctionner vos fédérations c'est une
règle que j'ai mise en place il y a un
peu plus d'un an qu'il faut bien avoir
en tête parce que évidemment c'est une
motivation supplémentaire pour faire
rentrer les adhésions et les cotisations
des élus pour poursuivre le
désendettement du parti en 2017 nous
allons poursuivre le remboursement de la
dette alors vous avez là un schéma qui
est très clair
en 2014 nous avions une dette de
74,5 millions d'euros nous avons
progressivement réduits en 2015 en 2016
la dette est aujourd'hui de 62,4
millions d'euros et à la fin de l'année
2017 quand nous aurons remboursé 5
millions et demi d'euros aux pull
bancaire poursuivi le remboursement de
notre dette auprès du groupe à
l'Assemblée nationale et commencer le
remboursement de la dette immobilière
c'est la SCI nous serons à la fin
d'année 2017 à une dette de
54,9 millions d'euros et c'est une bonne
nouvelle puisque c'est exactement la
valeur de notre siège donc nous avons en
deux ans remboursé 20 millions d'euros
redressés financièrement notre partie et
retrouver la confiance des banques des
militants et des Français
tout cela va permettre le financement de
l'action politique lorsqu'il faut
retenir sur ce point c'est que nous
avons pu donc grâce à cet excédent 2016
grâce à cette bonne gestion nous avons
pu dégager une enveloppe de 7,5 millions
d'euros destiné aux actions politiques
pour les élections présidentielles et
législatives je sais qu'il y a de
nombreux candidats aux élections
législatives qui m'ont interrogé est-ce
que nous serons aidés comme nous l'avons
été les années précédentes je n'ai pas
voulu répondre à cette question parce
que je n'avais pas de visibilité
suffisante sur les résultats de l'année
2016 et sur le budget de 2017 mais il a
été décidé lors du comité politique
présidé par Gérard Larcher cette semaine
au parti il a été décidé c'est une bonne
nouvelle de consacrer sur ces 7,5
millions d'euros 3 millions d'euros pour
les élections législatives et donc
chacun des candidats c'est la bonne
nouvelle que je vous annoncez ce matin
chaque année chacun des candidats aux
élections législatives recevra 6000
euros pour pouvoir financer sa campagne
[Applaudissements]
le parti est en ordre de marche et le
parti est à nouveau en capacité de vous
aider pour gagner l'élection
présidentielle et pour gagner et les
élections législatives
en conclusion
le budget 2017 est construit sur les
grands équilibres suivants des coups de
structures de 16,6 millions d'euros
intégralement couverts par la dotation
l'état de 18,6 millions d'euros des
dépenses d'action politique financées
par les autres recettes du parti le
budget 2017 se caractérise par des coups
de structures maîtrisées des prévisions
de recettes raisonnables des dépenses
d'actions politiques qui vont permettre
de nous mobiliser une situation
financière quand il se rétablir et
s'assainir grâce à la poursuite de notre
désendettement je voudrais remercier
bien dignement François Fillon remercier
également Nicolas Sarkozy grâce à qui
nous avons pu redresser le parti
remercier Laurent Wauquiez également
remercier Bernard Accoyer Gérard Larcher
les membres du comité financier le
Bureau politique la direction du parti
les militants vous tous qui vous battez
quotidiennement pour faire vivre notre
mouvement avec évidemment dans la
transparence que je vous ai présenté ce
matin vous le recevrez tous et il sera
transmis même dignement à la presse
parce que je pense qu'en matière
financière il faut que nous soyons
parfaitement transparent et chers amis
après avoir redressé le parti redresse
sur la France avec François Fillon en
avant pour la victoire
merci merci mon cher Daniel je veux
avant de procéder au vote je voudrais
saluer les différentes personnalités qui
nous ont rejoints Laurent Wauquiez
vice-président des républiques
président de la Région Rhône-Alpes
vertes
Bruno Retailleau président du groupe
parlementaire au Sénat
Virginie Calmels membres du comité
politique de François Fillon Valérie
Boyer porte-parole des républicains et
de nombreux parlementaires mes chers
amis je vais vous faire travailler je
vais vous demander de sortir le petit
carton qui figurait
votre dossier vous avez un carton avec
deux faces la bleue et la grise si vous
souhaitez
adopter ce budget je vais vous demander
de lever la partie bleue bleue tourner
vers mon côté la partie bleue de votre
carton si vous souhaitez rejeter ce
budget je vous demanderai de mettre en
avant la partie grise de ce carton je
vous demande donc d'approuver le budget
présenté par notre trésorier national
Daniel Fasquel
on passe au vote
et bien écoutez merci pour votre
fidélité et votre confiance en Daniel
Fasquel le budget donc adopté
nous allons passer à la deuxième partie
statutaire de notre ordre du jour avec
un point très important pour le
mouvement pour François Fillon pour
beaucoup d'entre vous qui sont ici dans
la salle les élections législatives avec
les investisseurs des candidats et
j'appelle Jean-François l'amour qui est
le président de notre commission
nationale d'investiture
oui mes chers amis bonjour bonjour à
tous et à toutes merci Luc de travail
que tu effectues salut bien sûr notre
président du Sénat Gérard Bruno Bernard
vous savez que c'est un très grand
honneur pour moi d'être devant vous en
ce conseil national comme président de
cette commission nationale d'investiture
un honneur un plaisir aussi car nous
sommes ici en famille notre mouvement
est une grande famille mes chers amis
une grande famille dans laquelle chacun
est animé par la volonté de servir la
France et les Français et cette famille
aujourd'hui elle est réunie autour de
François Fillon qui sera aujourd'hui
officiellement investi pour être notre
candidat à la présidence de la
République
nous sommes désormais tous engagés pour
faire gagner nos idées au mois de mai
prochain
évidemment rien n'est encore joué c'est
une campagne rude qui s'ouvre en ce
début d'année une campagne dans laquelle
nos adversaires ne nous épargnerions
aucun coup ni aucune outrance
une campagne exigeante où nous allons
convaincre les Français un par un
partout dans notre pays au mois de
novembre la primaire nous a laissé
entrevoir une formidable dynamique dans
l'ensemble de nos territoires
pour faire de cette dynamique une
réalité dans les urnes il nous faut
désormais jeter toutes nos forces dans
la bataille et lorsque nous aurons
obtenu la victoire à la présidentielle
nous ne serons simplement qu'au
commencement de cette aventure vous le
savez le quinquennat qui vient se
racrucial il sera crucial parce que nous
ne pouvons plus reculer face aux dangers
qui menace de faire imploser notre
modèle économique et social
il sera crucial également parce que dans
quelques mois dans quelques mois au long
sera dans l'obligation de renoncer à sa
succession alors que lui-même disait que
tout allait mieux or vous le savez très
bien rien ne va dans notre pays
nous savons que la France vit un moment
critique que l'alternative c'est où le
délitement ou le redressement il y a
quelques semaines vous êtes exprimé
massivement en faveur du projet de
François Fillon il est le seul le seul à
pouvoir enclencher ce redressement
vous avez été plusieurs millions à
plébisciter ce projet puissant qui a
clairement donné le rythme et le ton à
la campagne présidentielle
c'est dire mes chers amis si les
attentes sont immenses c'est dire si la
prochaine majorité n'aura pas le droit à
l'erreur ni même allez citation c'est
dire qu'elle devra faire bloc autour du
futur président de la République pour
accompagner les mesures qui voudra
impulser dès son élection
c'est la raison pour laquelle François
Fillon me nommant président de la
commission nationale d'investiture m'a
demandé de construire une majorité
parlementaire solide capable d'engager
les réformes nécessaires et de les mener
à leur terme ce principe a été ma
feuille de route au cours de ces
semaines de travail pour préparer ces
élections législatives je tiens à
remercier mes collègues j'envoie un
devant moi Roger carucci Alain marlex
qui se sont totalement vous pouvez les
applaudir
qui se sont totalement impliqués avec
moi dans cette mission je tiens
également à remercier tous nos collègues
de la commission nationale d'investiture
qui ont participé à nos travaux et qui
ont siéger encore hier matin
aujourd'hui nous vous proposons des
investitures qui nous permettront à la
fois de réaliser une large victoire au
législative et de commencer le
quinquennat dans les meilleures
conditions
je vous demande d'accueillir et
d'applaudir François Fillon
[Applaudissements]
François nous parlions il y a quelques
instants du travail de la commission
nationale
d'investiture qui te permettra d'avoir
une majorité solide permettant d'engager
dès ton élection
un plan de réforme un projet de réforme
puissant pour notre pays mes chers amis
nous vous proposons justement des
instituts qui tiennent compte de
l'ensemble des sensibilités qui se sont
exprimées à la primaire de la droite et
du centre
un certain nombre de circonscriptions
ont ainsi été réservés pour permettre un
accord global avec le Centre nous vous
proposons des investitures qui font
monter une nouvelle génération d'élus
puisque les trois quarts des candidats
investis dans les circonscriptions de
reconquête sont de nouveaux candidats
nous vous proposons enfin des
investitures qui permettront de
présenter des femmes candidates dans 50%
des circonscriptions de reconquête la
prochaine majorité présidentielle sera
donc profondément rajeuni et féminisé
[Applaudissements]
alors je vous parle la commission
nationale d'investiture a avancer aussi
loin qu'elle le pouvait pour la
préparation des élections législatives
pour poursuivre ce travail dans les
circonscriptions encore réservées comme
pour les cas de députés qui seraient
touchés par l'interdiction du cumul le
comité politique présidé par Gérard
Larcher a établi le principe d'une
commission Haddock sur proposition de
notre secrétaire général que je remercie
également de son appui et de sa présence
en commission nationale d'investiture je
vous soumets la liste suivante pour la
composition de cette commission qui
rassemblera toutes les sensibilités de
notre mouvement et dans laquelle je
siesterais comme Président je vais les
énumérer à la Marleix Roger caoutchi
Gérard Larcher bien sûr Nadine Morano
Axel Poniatowski Bernard à cahier Bruno
retaillod Christian Jacob Isabelle le
CALENNEC à ni Genval dans dalmanin
Sébastien Lecornu Caroline cailleux Luc
Chatel notre président Jean-François
Copé Dominique Bussereau Sophie prima
Damien Abad Véronique louvagi et
Grégoire de la série mes chers amis je
vais donc à présent vous proposer de
valider par vote à la fois les candidats
choisis par la commission nationale
d'investiture pour les élections
législatives et la composition de la
commission Haddock qui sera chargée de
se prononcer sur les circonscriptions
encore réservées à ce jour alors
reprenez sous l'autorité bienveillante
de notre président de votre petit carton
qui est pour
merci à vous merci mes chers amis
des candidats choisis par la commission
nationale d'investiture pour les
élections législatives sont donc investi
et je leur souhaite bon vent pour ces
élections
et donc la commission
un doc est donc installé elle poursuivra
je peux vous le dire son travail avec
beaucoup de dynamisme mais aussi il faut
bien dire
une certaine volonté de défendre nos
idées et une majorité très forte
François qui te permettra je le dis tout
à l'heure de transformer de réformer
profondément notre pays nous sommes donc
mes chers amis en ordre de marche
partout dans notre beau pays pour
amplifier le mouvement qui s'est dessiné
à la primaire nous sommes en ordre de
marche pour faire gagner nos candidats
dans les circonscriptions et pour porter
François Fillon à la présidence de la
République
merci merci cher Jean-François je veux
vraiment remercier l'ensemble des
membres de la commission nationale
d'investiture sous l'autorité de
Jean-François Lamour et précédemment sur
l'autorité de Christian Estrosi avec à
ses côtés nos devises présidents à la
Marleix et Roger carochi c'est compliqué
vous savez de faire les investitures il
y a beaucoup de représentants des uns
des autres je crois qu'on est arrivé
vraiment un bon accord des candidats
comme tu l'as dit qui incarnent le
renouvellement dans notre famille
politique le renouvellement dans la
France a besoin mon cher François ta
famille politique le Parlement de ton
parti est aujourd'hui rassemblé il est
rassemblé dans ces différentes
sensibilités mais il est rassemblé
autour de toi à tes côtés parce que nous
voulons te faire gagner au printemps
prochain pour changer la France
et je voudrais
en quelques images te présenter vous
présenter les visages qui vont porter
nos couleurs au cours des prochaines
élections législatives
nous on mettra toutes nos forces dans la
bataille pour offrir un François Fillon
si les Français lui font l'honneur de
les lire le 7 mai 2017 une large
majorité à l'Assemblée une majorité
solide qui lui permettra de mettre en
œuvre son programme de redressement
enfin à l'occasion de ce conseil
national je voudrais souhaiter bon
courage à tous les candidats investis et
en particulier aux jeunes qui se lancent
pour la première fois dans cette
aventure mon combat sera de ressouder
notre territoire pour qu'il redevienne
un et indivisibles et pour que chacun y
trouve sa place je suis heureuse
aujourd'hui de nous voir tous réunis
lors de ce conseil national autour de
notre candidat François Fillon et je
suis convaincue avec François Fillon que
nous arriverons à faire revivre notre
bien commun la nation ça sera avec
honneur plaisir enthousiasme et passion
que je défendrai à l'Assemblée nationale
la politique de François Fillon et
aujourd'hui pour ce premier conseil
national derrière notre candidat je
pourrais dire aux côtés de notre
candidat l'occasion de lancer un grand
appel à tous les Français à participer
au débat et à écouter nos propositions
ce conseil national on vous l'a tous dit
extrêmement important car après une
primaire qui a été très belle une
primaire pleine de succès nous devons
tous être unis un mot pour ce Conseil
National Union union avec François
Fillon union contre les attaques tous
unis nous allons gagner la
présidentielle et nous lui donnerons une
majorité très forte à l'Assemblée
nationale alors on y va on y va tous
pour que la France gagne vive la
république vie François Fillon et vive
les LR
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais saluer un certain nombre de
nos personnalités qui nous ont rejoints
Gérald Darmanin secrétaire général
adjoint des républicains
je veux saluer la présence de Bruno Le
Maire parmi nous
les chers amis la parole l'état Annie
Genevard la secrétaire général adjointe
de notre mouvement
[Applaudissements]
bien chers amis bienvenue à tous pour ce
conseil national d'importance et très
attendu monsieur le Président sherluc
bravo à tous les candidats qui sont
désormais investis et merci cher
Jean-François pour cette tâche qui
n'était pas facile et qui n'est pas
encore terminé
pour laquelle tu as montré des qualités
que nous te connaissions tu as je crois
j'en suis certaine parfaitement remplie
la mission que François t'a confié de
constituer pour lui une majorité solide
il y a quelques semaines François Fillon
et je leur remercie chaleureusement
m'a proposé d'intégrer l'équipe
dirigeante des républicains comme
secrétaire général adjointe aux côtés de
Bernard accueillez avec Gérald Darmanin
qui a été notre collègue à l'Assemblée
nationale jusqu'à ce qu'il ravisse
brillamment à la gauche la mairie de
Tourcoing j'y retrouve mes amis
vice-présidents Isabelle le Callennec
Laurent Wauquiez et notre trésorier
Daniel Pasquet
nous avons donc sous la responsabilité
de Bernard la tâche de maître notre
mouvement en ordre de marche pour les
deux élections majeures qui nous
attendent que notre pays espère tant ce
gouvernement calamiteux la mise à mal
pour ceux comme moi qui viennent de
vivre ce mandat dans l'opposition vous
n'imaginez pas à quel point nous avons
souffert pour notre pays au fil des lois
mauvaises des lois délétères qui ont été
votées malgré nous notre mouvement a
toujours été d'une efficacité
extraordinaire pour conduire des
batailles c'est dans notre ADN
soumis à l'exercice inédit des primaires
il n'a pas tardé à se remettre en ordre
de marche car nous sommes tendus vers un
seul objectif qu'appelle notre chance
des responsabilités
l'alternance avec la victoire de
François Fillon
[Applaudissements]
merci
merci à Nicolas à Alain à Bruno à
Nathalie à Jean-Frédéric à Jean-François
pour leur fair-play et leur loyauté
applaudissons les également
avec Gérald et en accord avec Bernard à
coyez notre secrétaire général nous nous
sommes répartis la tâche
agerald les fédérations mais il voulait
expliquera et pour moi chers amis
candidats la constitution d'un pôle
d'appui au candidats aux élections
législatives je veux que nos
577 candidats
particulièrement les primo-candidats
puissent trouver auprès des républicains
une oreille toujours attentive des
ressources et des conseils que ce soit
en matière pratique juridique financière
mais surtout surtout politique ce point
est capital car chacun de vous sera le
relais de François Fillon sur le terrain
notre victoire au législatives découle
en grande partie de celle de notre
candidat je dirais même qu'elle ne prend
son sens qu'avec la victoire de François
Fillon à la présidentielle
et vous verrez chers amis jusqu'à la
présidentielle c'est de François qu'on
vous parlera de son programme de son
projet de notre projet et il faudra que
vous soyez en mesure d'en parler tout
comme vous devrez expliquer ce qu'a été
la gestion catastrophique de François
Hollande et de ses gouvernements nous
vous fournirons des argumentaires et je
réfléchis à la mise en oeuvre très
prochainement avec l'équipe des
républicains à des formations très
opérationnelles maintenant que les
candidats sont investis pour la plus
grande part nous allons pouvoir sans
tarder leur proposer ses formations
mes chers amis candidats je veux vous
redire tout mon soutien et mes vœux de
réussite le mandat de députés est un
très beau mandat un mandat passionnant
et lui en 2012 je serai candidate comme
vous à vos côtés je vous souhaite de
tout cœur de connaître ce bonheur je
vous y aiderai de mon mieux avec notre
équipe et en lien avec les fédérations
dont je voudrais saluer les présidents
et les secrétaires départementaux très
nombreux ce matin
[Applaudissements]
alors chers amis en route et pas en
marche en route pour porter François
Fillon à la victoire et lui donner une
belle et franche majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale
[Applaudissements]
merci cher ami ce soutien à nos
candidats et évidemment très importants
et merci de l'avoir mis en place je
voudrais saluer la présence de Valérie
Pécresse présidente du Conseil régional
d'Île-de-France
l'arrivée de notre président de groupe à
l'Assemblée nationale Christian Jacob
et j'appelle notre vice-présidente
Isabelle le caleennec apprendre la
parole
chers amis chers François notre dernier
Conseil national a eu lieu le 2 juillet
2016 ici même c'était souvenez-vous en
présence de celui qui aura présidé l'UMP
de 2004 à 2016 notre pays de 2007 à 2012
et les républicains pendant deux ans je
veux à cette tribune et très sincèrement
comme vous l'avez fait sherluc et chère
daniel lui rendre hommage devant le
Parlement de notre mouvement vous l'avez
compris il s'agit de Nicolas Sarkozy
il a ressoudé notre famille
il l'a remise au travail
il s'est engagé pour et dans la primaire
de la droite et du centre un exercice
auquel nous n'étions pas habitués mais
dont nous nous sommes plutôt pas mal
sortis même la gauche a du reconnaître
que ce fut un succès une primaire qui
fut avant tout un débat d'idées entre 7
personnalités de talent qui ont leurs
ambitions leurs caractères mais savent
aussi qu'ils appartiennent à une même
famille ils sont capables de se
rassembler quand l'essentiel est en jeu
ils ont tenu promesse en soutenant tous
sans exception et dès le soir de son
élection celui dont les sondages ne
donnaient pas cher mais qui a pourtant
réuni près de 3 millions de votants sur
sa candidature deux électeurs sur 3 il
est désormais notre candidat je veux
bien sûr parler de François Fillon
alors à toutes celles et tous ceux qui
ont été les artisans de ce bel exercice
démocratique c'est-à-dire vous tous ici
réunis ce matin et quelques furent vos
choix à la primaire j'adresse à cet
instant un immense merci nous sommes à
100 jours de la présidentielle des 23
avril et cette mai la veille en
outre-mer
il ne vous aura pas échappé que ce n'est
pas gagné et qu'il faut donc rester
concentré sur l'objectif depuis que nous
avons désigné notre champion il fait en
effet l'objet de toutes les attaques et
la créativité en la matière et sans
limite les coûts en l'occurrence
viennent de partout passons sur les
caricatures incessantes de adversaires
politiques nous n'avons rien à en
attendre mais intéressons-nous plutôt à
ceux qui nous interpellent ce que nous
côtoyons tous les jours dans le cadre de
nos responsabilités des lunes nationaux
locaux ou de simples militants les
républicains ils peuvent manifester des
inquiétudes ou des incompréhensions sur
tel ou telle mesure du projet ils
peuvent même souhaiter que le programme
soit modifié généralement quand ils ne
le se sont pas encore totalement
approprié
François Fillon l'a dit est répété
son projet pour la France est réfléchi
et cohérent
il est le fruit de ses convictions de
ces rencontres avec les Français et de
son expérience d'hommes d'État son
projet peut être enrichi approfondi mais
pas des naturels il ne cède pas à la
démagogie et empreinte clairement le
chemin de la vérité et du courage
nous pouvons être persuadés que la
comparaison avec ses concurrents est à
l'avantage de François Fillon notre
mission votre mission est désormais d'en
convaincre les Français fort de notre
soif de reconquête après cinq ans
demande à désastreux de François
Hollande et conscient des attentes
fortes de notre pays je crois que nous
le pouvons et je ne doute pas un seul
instant que nous trouverons les mots
pour le dire et rassembler les Français
nous avons un chef
nous avons un projet
nous sommes le premier parti de France
nous avons la volonté le carré d'as est
entre nos mains
et de surcroît nous ne sommes pas seuls
nous pouvons nous appuyer dans chacune
des fédérations sur les 1500 comités
locaux
issus de la société civile ils ont joué
un rôle majeur dans la primaire et je
pense particulièrement aux jeunes et aux
femmes sur lesquelles nous fondons
beaucoup d'espoir toutes et tous nous
aideront à faire connaître et partager
notre dessin pour la France
la période des vœux bassons plein et
Corneille a inspiré ma conclusion
nous partîmes 500 mais par un prompt
renfort nous nous vivons 3000 en
arrivant au port nous partîmes plus de 4
millions mais par un gros effort nous
nous vivions plus de 23 millions en
arrivant au port oui nous le pouvons oui
nous le ferons alors belle année à tous
et surtout bonne santé
[Applaudissements]
juste un mot je voudrais vous savez il y
a une chose importante en politique soit
on est dedans soit on est dehors bah
c'est pareil pour les gens qui sont au
fond de la salle soit vous êtes à
l'intérieur et vous écoutez soit vous
êtes dehors et vous pouvez discuter et
donner des interviews simplement par
respect pour tous nos collègues qui sont
à l'intérieur et qui manifestement ont
du mal à nous entendre
nous avons Salvé nos candidats aux
élections législatives je veux continuer
à le faire je veux saluer Muriel Delor
jury qui sera candidate dans l'Aude je
veux saluer leur esquieu qui sera
candidate à Paris je veux saluer elle
est venue avec son fan club je veux
venir je veux saluer Laurence ça y est
qui sera candidate dans la
circonscription des Français de
l'étranger en Espagne je veux saluer
Sandrine Richard qui sera candidate à
Paris je veux saluer Arnaud Julien qui
sera candidat dans l'Hérault je veux
saluer Daniel sauvette qui sera candidat
en Charente et Alexandre vacandet qui
sera candidat dans le Rhône tous nos
espoirs sont en vous nous sommes à vos
côtés pour ce combat
je voudrais maintenant appeler Gérald
Darmanin secrétaire général adjoint des
républicains
[Applaudissements]
cher Luc merci
depuis ce début du mois de janvier
j'essaye de d'honorer les fonctions que
mon confier François Fillon et Bernard
cahier dans secrétaire général comme
secrétaire général adjoint chargé
fédération à côté de mon ami et
collègues et Genval et depuis maintenant
quasiment un mois je parcours les
fédérations pour les réunions pour les
vœux j'imagine comme chacun d'entre vous
et je voudrais moi aussi et j'aurais
pour les applaudisse saluer les
secrétaires départementaux les
secrétaires départementaux adjoint qui
font un travail formidable pour notre
Mouvement pour la primaire car sans les
républicains jamais l'organisation des
primaires n'aurait été possible
et en parcourant la France en parcourant
aussi ma région des Hauts de France je
pense à mon Président que vous avez
Bertrand je retire
je retire un enseignement de ce que je
peux entendre ici ou là et de ce que
nous disent et nous répète nos militants
et nos sympathisants
ils nous disent que nous devons tous
mettre notre énergie pour gagner
l'élection présidentielle non pas de
2022 mais de 2017
ils disent que nous devons être motivés
pour être unis et confiant parce que non
seulement la victoire de François Fillon
est nécessité pour la France mais que la
victoire de la majorité parlementaire
réformera enfin notre pays
qui peut penser en effet et c'est le bon
sens populaire même
que nous pourrions construire que ce
soit sur la défaite de mes et de joie
qui peut penser en effet nationalement
comme localement que l'on peut bâtir
quelque chose sur un champ de ruine et
un champ de mine qui peut penser en
effet que la France qui a trop souffert
de 50 socialisme et de Monsieur Hollande
peut penser aujourd'hui qu'elle peut se
payer le luxe d'attendre 5 ans
supplémentaires personne ne peut le
penser car en 2022 il sera trop tard
il sera trop tard pour réformer le pays
il sera trop tard pour donner confiance
à notre jeunesse
il sera trop tard pour ne pas désespérer
définitivement les classes populaires
il sera trop tard pour redonner du
pouvoir d'achat et du travail à nos
ouvriers à notre industrie il sera trop
tard pour encourager nos entrepreneurs
il sera trop tard pour relever notre
économie
toutes nos énergies et les grandes
doivent être utilisé pour faire gagner
François Fillon la victoire doit être
notre combat quotidien et le service des
fédérations cher Bernard sera au service
évidemment de la campagne de notre
candidat l'ensemble de ces militants
pour organiser en lien total avec
l'équipe de campagne de François Fillon
la victoire de François Fillon et de sa
future majorité parlementaire
j'ai eu l'honneur d'être directeur de
campagne de Nicolas Sarkozy ce fut un
très grand honneur pour moi ce fut une
très belle campagne
aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
Nicolas Sarkozy n'a plus de directeur de
campagne il a plus de porte-parole il
n'a pas non plus d'héritiers mais il a
eu un message notamment le soir du
premier tour de l'élection primaire
il a encouragé la famille politique
qu'il a reconstruit à rester unis
et à faire tout faire pour la victoire
de François Villon la défaite
la défaite que nous pourrions avoir si
nous étions des Unis
si nous n'écoutons pas le message du
président Sarkozy cette défaite non
seulement soit une grande défaite pour
notre famille politique mais serait un
crime contre notre pays
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est vrai que les Français sont
impatient qui sont contestataires bien
souvent français varie
mais les Français dont je suis sûr sont
motivés
attendent espère un gaulliste à nouveau
à la tête du pays
et le gaullisme c'est le rassemblement
c'est aussi de fidèle
au message général de Gaulle qui
souvenez-vous en 1943 et cette phrase va
très bien notre candidat pas très bien à
nous candidats et va très bien
l'ensemble des militants soyons ferme
purs et fidèle car au bout du monde il y
a la plus grande gloire celle des hommes
qui n'ont pas cédé je vous remercie
merci Gérald je vais maintenant donner
la parole à Valérie Pécresse président
du Conseil régional d'Île-de-France
[Applaudissements]
faut faire attention mes chers amis je
suis extrêmement heureuse de vous
accueillir tous ici en Île-de-France une
belle région que nous avons conquise de
haute lutte après 17 ans de socialisme
il y a un an alors
alors encore un grand merci à tous ceux
d'entre vous qui ont tout donné tout
donné pour cette belle victoire qui nous
rend tous si fière et comme promis et
bien depuis un an nous mettons en œuvre
un programme de franche rupture pour
faire de cette région une région
conquérante exemplaire et réconciliés
alors je sais pas si vous vous souvenez
du du refrain de la Coupe du Monde
victorieuse de 98 et 1 et 2 et 3 0
on a eu un les municipales et de les
départementales et trois les régionales
et bien maintenant arrive la mère des
élections l'élection présidentielle la
dernière étape avant l'alternance mais
aussi la plus dure à franchir notre
responsabilité je pèse mes mots et
historique nous devons redresser la
France et rendre à nos compatriotes
l'espérance
alors tout a bien commencé nous sortons
d'une primaire exemplaire et nous avons
toutes les raisons d'en être fier et à
mon tour je crois que nous devons saluer
ensemble l'élégance le fair-play et le
panache de tous les candidats et
particulièrement celle de Nicolas
Sarkozy et Alain Juppé qui ont
immédiatement appelé à te soutenir
François
[Applaudissements]
il y a eu le temps des préférences des
différences des nuances mais je le dis
il est derrière nous voici venu le temps
du rassemblement pour gagner les règles
du jeu on les connaît pendant les
primaires on choisit après la primaire
on s'unit les électeurs de la droite et
du centre ont désignait clairement un
candidat mais ils ont aussi choisi une
ligne politique ils ont choisi la force
de l'expérience mais ils ont aussi
choisi la puissance de la réforme
radicale nous devons respecter leur
choix et faire bloc pour le redressement
national nous devons nous rassembler
sans état d'âme et je dirais même tout
feu tout flamme voici venu lors du
combat collectif parce que nous voulons
transformer l'essai parce que nous
voulons gagner et parce que nous devons
sauver la France et que c'est maintenant
ou jamais
alors François tu as dirigé pendant 5
ans le gouvernement mais tu avais mené
auparavant en tant que ministre de
nombreuses réformes les télécoms l'école
les retraites les Français te
connaissent ils t'ont vu à l'oeuvre et
ceux qui veulent te caricaturer en
seront pour leur frais tu es droit et de
droite tu égoïste et humaniste tu chéris
notre histoire et nos terroirs mais tu
aimes aussi te projeter dans la
modernité voilà ce dont la France a
besoin
quand tu es venu me soutenir pour les
régionales à Nogent tu as commencé par
un retentissant fonce Valérie
et bien moi aujourd'hui je viens te dire
fonce François on est derrière toi
parce que tu as la stature et
l'expérience nécessaire pour relever une
fonction présidentielle abîmée parce que
tu as le courage et l'audace des vrais
réformateurs qui tiennent bon même dans
la tourmente et permettez-moi de vous
dire que je parle d'expérience parce que
je l'ai constaté personnellement lors de
la réforme des universités parce que tu
as l'autorité qui imposent à tous le
respect et parce que la République a
trop reculé le populisme d'une marine Le
Pen ou d'un Mélenchon se nourrissent
aujourd'hui de cette impuissance
publique et malheureusement le
quinquennat que vient qui vient de
s'écouler à considérablement aggraver la
situation madame tobira a amplifié le
sentiment d'impunité des délinquants
madame Vallaud-Belkacem à nivelé par le
bas le collège
les audaces de Monsieur Macron le
mauvais génie du matraquage fiscal qui
nous a fait tant payé d'impôts les
audaces de Monsieur Macron se sont
résumés à la libéralisation des autocars
et à l'ouverture de certains commerces
certains dimanches Macron c'est
finalement l'ultime avatar de François
Hollande celui qui commande si bien la
situation et qui agit si peu alors c'est
impuissance publique elle se ressent
aussi sur le front de la sécurité
quotidienne de la lutte contre
l'islamisme radical mais aussi de
l'arrivée sur notre territoire d'un flux
incontrôlés de migrants et la République
exemplaire a sombré
alors oui le quinquennat de François
Hollande a abîmé la France et pourtant
face à la brutalité de leur bilan qui a
plongé des millions de Français dans la
colère la désillusion et la difficulté
les candidats de la primaire socialiste
semble réfugiés dans le déni ils ne sont
responsables de rien comptable de rien
coupable de rien est-ce que vous les
avez regardé jeudi dernier
c'était un peu ennuyeux je le reconnais
c'était surtout surréaliste je sais pas
si vous allez les reconnaître il y avait
le seul ministre de l'éducation
nationale qui n'a jamais fait de rentrer
scolaire
celui qui s'est fait virer avant Benoît
Hamon si vous jouez pas au jeu des
questions réveillez-vous un peu là oh il
y avait aussi le ministre qui croyait
que porter une marinière suffirait à
redresser notre industrie
bon ça y est il y avait aussi l'auteur
de la calamiteuse et coûteuse réforme
des rythmes scolaires le ministre de
l'éducation nationale qui a fait faire
du macramé aux enfants au lieu de leur
apprendre à lire écrire et compter
Vincent Peillon bien et puis il y avait
aussi le sportif
il y a certains sportifs qui
s'entraînent à courir le 50 mètres lui
c'est le seul Français qui pratique le
49-3
il faut en 32 mois un record mais résumé
l'originalité de ses propositions à la
suppression de l'article 49-3 de la
Constitution comme il le fait
aujourd'hui permettez-moi de vous dire
c'est un peu court au regard des
problèmes de la France c'était Manuel
Valls où l'avais reconnu alors c'est
vrai que jeudi soir sur TF1 on se serait
cru devant le maillon faible sauf que
les candidats étaient tous des maillons
faibles alors il y a urgence à tous les
sortir
de l'autre côté de la galaxie politique
se joue la saga de la PME familiale des
Le Pen un mixte entre Dallas et les
Borgia
l'attente des avelaniès la nièce attaque
la tente quant au Père et au grand-père
d'abord ils veulent le mettre en maison
de retraite avant de venir lui piquer
son argent
il se déchire il ne s'accorde sur rien
une bonne primaire ça leur ferait
peut-être du bien
ça leur permettrait en tout cas
d'élaborer un programme un programme
crédible qui n'emmène pas la France dans
le mur mais au Front national les idées
sont agiométrie variable pour ne pas
dire à géométrie et électorale ainsi
après avoir mis toute leur énergie à
essayer de conquérir les régions et de
venir présidente de région avec sa nièce
voilà que Madame Le Pen souhaite
supprimer les régions cher Bruno alors
avant c'était le Sénat faites-vous les
supprimer mais depuis qu'elle a ses
notes sénateur chargée rare elle pense
que le Sénat finalement c'est très utile
voilà alors on a envie de lui dire vous
perdez les présidences de région vous
supprimez les régions et quand vous
aurez perdu la présidentielle vous
supprimerez l'État
non quand même pas alors quel contraste
avec toi François qui nous propose de
faire des réformes profondes et
audacieuses dans un esprit de justice je
tiens à le dire ici avec de telles
réformes nos voisins ont vaincu la
fatalité du chômage de masse grâce à
elle on peut relocaliser des emplois
industriels innover et créé les futurs
champions économiques de demain grâce à
elle on peut revaloriser le travail
augmenter les salaires nets et
permettent aux Français de vivre mieux
grâce à elle on peut épanouir des
familles dans lesquelles les femmes
n'auront pas à choisir entre travailler
et faire des enfants grâce à elle on
peut donner un avenir à notre jeunesse
ici en France
alors avec le redressement de notre
économie tu défendras aussi une
république intransigeante une république
du respect oui dans notre République la
loi sera respectée nous devons avoir le
courage de le dire si c'est l'honneur de
la France d'accueillir les réfugiés
persécutés dans leur pays en revanche il
est de notre droit souverain de limiter
l'immigration économiques car ces
migrants nous n'avons plus les moyens de
leur donner du travail de les loger de
les intégrer les illégaux les
clandestins doivent rentrer chez eux
c'est notre impuissance à faire
respecter la loi et à maîtriser les flux
migratoires qui nourrit tous les
extrêmes c'était ton message de Nice
dans notre République les forces de
l'ordre les forces de secours seront
respectées François tu l'as dit à
Viry-Châtillon la loi des bandes ne peut
pas prévaloir sur la loi commune et il
ne peut pas y avoir de zones de
l'endroit dans notre République
dans notre République les professeurs
seront respectés les actes d'incivilité
les violences se multiplient aujourd'hui
dans nos écoles on le sait et il nous
faut des enseignants de qualité pour que
l'ascenseur social et l'intégration
fonctionnent dans notre République
égyptien les femmes seront respectées il
y a un symbole dévastateur de notre
impuissance à protéger la dignité des
femmes c'est le port impuni de la burqa
sur notre sol
vous le savez c'est un combat que je
mène avec constance et je le dis dans
notre République la femme se promène à
visage découvert
[Applaudissements]
dans notre République tous les cultes
devront respecter la même Charte de la
laïcité ce que l'on a demandé par le
passé aux chrétiens et aux Gifs de
France nous devons aujourd'hui le
demander à tous les musulmans de France
prêchés en français former les imams
arrêter le financement étranger des
mosquées contre les écoles hors contrat
leur demander aussi de condamner
fermement le terrorisme nous devons
avoir le courage de faire ce qui n'a pas
été fait depuis des années pour lutter
contre la barbarie islamiste qui tente
d'endoctriner une partie de notre
jeunesse et de lui faire haïr la France
il y a urgence
cette république intransigeante cette
république du respect François qui sort
à l'incarner parce que tu seras toi-même
un président sobre et respectable un
président à l'autorité naturelle un
président décentralisateurs qui libèrent
les énergies la société qui délègue et
qui fait confiance faute de cap faute
d'intégrité faute d'autorité faute de
justice la France notre France est
abîmée nous savons pourtant que nous
avons tous les atouts pour la redresser
que nous sommes travailleurs ginative et
généreux alors François porte notre
espoir celui de la fierté française
retrouvée
[Applaudissements]
l'amour de la France le refus du déclin
la volonté d'un sursaut voilà ce qui
nous anime dans cette campagne François
c'est ton moment c'est ton destin nous
sommes à tes côtés nous voulons te
donner la force en 1944 dans le journal
Combat Albert Camus écrivait notre monde
n'a pas besoin d'âme tiède mais de cœur
brûlant et bien aujourd'hui dans cette
salle il y a pas d'un tiède il n'y a que
des cœurs qui brûlent avec toi de
changer la France fausse François pour
la République et pour la France
merci Valérie
je voudrais saluer notre ancien Premier
ministre ancien président du Conseil
national Jean-Pierre Raffarin
et vous présentez à nouveau un certain
nombre de nos candidats aux élections
législatives
dès demain je serai sur le terrain pour
convaincre les Français de voter
François Fillon c'est le seul qui pourra
vraiment remettre la France à niveau je
souhaite bonne chance enfin à notre
conseil national qui se tient
aujourd'hui je suis sûr que nous sommes
extrêmement nombreux et que nous allons
prouver que la droite est en or de
bataille rassemblez et réconcilier et
que nous allons gagner toutes les
échéances de 2017 un juin prochain
offrant un autre candidat François
Fillon le prochain Président de la
République une majorité large et solide
pour redresser notre pays je sais
pouvoir compter sur chacun d'entre vous
alors en route pour la victoire en route
pour la reconquête de nos territoires
bien j'ai envie de dire que notre pays a
besoin également d'un fort redressement
et si je peux aux côtés de François
Fillon de son prochain gouvernement
apporté mon expérience
redressement de la France pour que nos
compatriotes soient de nouveaux fiers
d'être c'est notre premier conseil
national depuis les primaires donc nous
allons aujourd'hui toute la famille
ensemble réunie
discuter échanger et bien entendu je
n'en doute pas à l'instant nous serons
tous ensemble unis derrière François
Fillon pour pouvoir lui permettre d'être
notre prochain Président de la
République au mois de mai nous devons
nous mobiliser pour réussir l'alternance
autour de François Fillon et donc
œuvrer de toutes nos forces pour
redonner l'espoir aux Français et
réaffirmer notre unité nationale pour
une France fière et fraternelle
merci et bonne chance à tous je voudrais
maintenant appeler Laurent Wauquiez
vice-président des républicains
mes amis
c'est la première fois que notre conseil
national se réunit depuis les primaires
et ça fait chaud au cœur parce que moi
j'aime ces moments où on vous retrouve
et c'est d'abord vers vous que je veux
me tourner vous qui êtes les forces
vives de notre famille politique
il est à la mode chez certains de
dénigrer les partis politiques et bien
nous nous croyons exactement l'inverse
sans vous rien n'aurait été possible la
réussite de la primaire c'est vous la
tenue des bureaux de vote c'est vous les
militantes terrains c'est vous
l'engagement des bénévoles c'est vous et
la victoire de François Fillon ce sera
vous vous êtes les militants de notre
famille politique et je suis fier des
républicains
on est en 2017
ouf
ça y est on y est presque
cinq ans mais qu'est-ce que ça nous a
semblé long cinq ans de socialisme et
nous avons enfin l'espoir de nous en
débarrasser alors croyez-moi la victoire
personne n'a l'intention de la laisser
passer
François
la France a besoin de ta victoire
elle a besoin de ta victoire parce qu'il
faut mettre fin à la déconstruction du
pays par la gauche
ne vous y trompez pas ils appliquent une
vraie idéologie de déconstruction
une idéologie de déconstruction quant
tobira expliquait que la justice ne doit
pas punir une idéologie de
déconstruction quand Najet
Vallaud-Belkacem supprime l'enseignement
de l'histoire
une idéologie de déconstruction comme
Manuel Valls encore maintenant défend le
RSA pour les jeunes ils ne font pas
d'erreurs ils appliquent une idéologie
cette idéologie de la déconstruction
c'est celle mes amis qui a battu les
frontières c'est celle qui déteste la
famille c'est celle qui refuse
l'autorité c'est celle qui nourrit le
communautarisme c'est celle qui veut un
monde sans identité et sans racines nous
nous ne voulons pas de ce monde et nous
réclamons de pouvoir transmettre à nos
enfants nos valeurs
alors pour gagner il faut 3 conditions
la première condition c'est l'unité
j'ai soutenu Nicolas Sarkozy
vous me connaissez
vous me connaissez je ne renie jamais
mes engagements je n'ai pas l'habitude
de dire les choses à moitié je reste
fidèle à ces valeurs je n'oublie pas ce
qu'il a apporté à notre famille
politique et comme nous tous j'ai été
touché par sa dignité le soir du premier
tour quand il a trouvé les mots pour
t'apporter son soutien c’était son
honneur non n'oublions pas Nicolas
Sarkozy
[Applaudissements]
et aujourd'hui François
nous avons tous le devoir du
rassemblement
nous voyons bien ce que certains
voudraient écrire depuis quelques jours
alors que ce matin les choses soient
claires François tu as tout notre
soutien et nous serons tous à tes côtés
tous
et c'est nous François
l'unité ce n'est pas l'uniformité tu
n'as pas besoin de clones autour de toi
tu n'as pas besoin de courtisans il faut
des paroles fortes et des convictions
claires Philippe Seguin n'était pas
Jacques Chirac et il s'est battu pour sa
victoire en 1995 tu n'es pas Nicolas
Sarkozy et tu t'es battu pour sa
victoire en 2007 c'est cette diversité
qui fera notre force rassembler et
déterminer nous irons chercher cette
victoire en 2017
la seconde condition c'est d'assumer nos
convictions toutes nos convictions on
arrête de s'excuser d'être de droite
François ton succès à la primaire l'a
montré tu as compris que les Français ne
demandaient pas l'immobilisme ils
veulent le changement ils ne veulent pas
une droite qui en dise moins ils veulent
une droite qui en face plus ils ne
veulent pas Monsieur le Premier Ministre
Édouard Balladur que nous avons
l'honneur et le plaisir d'accueillir
merci de votre présence comme à chaque
fois à nos côtés merci monsieur le
Premier ministre
ils ne veulent pas mes amis une droite
qui en disent moins ils veulent une
droite qui en face plus ils ne veulent
pas renoncer à leur valeur ils attendent
des politiques qui ont une colonne
vertébrale nous sommes de droite et nous
sommes fiers de nos valeurs et la gauche
ne nous donne plus de leçon
en 2017 ce n'est plus la CGT qui dictera
ses volonté au pays et il faudra avoir
le courage de revenir sur toutes ces
lois socialistes et je pense évidemment
à la loi Taubira
alors oui François tu as raison de dire
qu'il faudra des économies sur la
dépense publique tu as raison de dire
qu'il y aura demain moins de
fonctionnaires et oui il faudra mener
les réformes indispensables à commencer
par une vraie réforme du régime de
retraite parce que la seule réforme qui
vaille c'est celle qui mettra à égalité
les retraites du public et du privé et
qui supprimera la totalité des régimes
spéciaux
oui
oui c'est ce courage qu'attendent les
Français et ce sont ces efforts qu'ils
sont prêts à soutenir parce que ces
efforts ce sont des efforts de justice
Vous avez vu la gauche
ils ont supprimé les heures
supplémentaires ils veulent le RSA jeune
tout en enlevant les bourses au méritent
et maintenant leur dernière trouvaille
c'est le revenu universel superbe
invention tamponnée pur produit
socialiste gagner plus en ne faisant
rien
[Applaudissements]
et bien pour nous
le travail et l'effort ce ne sont pas
des gros mots alors oui nous devons
parler à la France qui travaille
la droite à laquelle nous croyons ces
celles qui défend la valeur travail le
travail des classes moyennes le travail
des artisans le travail des ouvriers le
travail des agriculteurs le travail de
ceux qui se donnent du mal et qui a la
fin du mois constatent chaque année en
France qu'on gagne à peine plus en se
levant le matin qu'en restant ces soirs
parce que c'est cela la réalité de notre
pays aujourd'hui celui qui travaille
n'est pas payé du fruit de ses efforts
et ça nous ne devons pas l'accepter
oui mes amis oui
nous pouvons demander des efforts aux
Français ils y sont prêts ils attendent
simplement de nous que nous remettions
le travail au cœur de la société
française en 2017 ce sont ces Français
qu'il faut entendre après 5 ans d'impôts
socialiste la droite doit revaloriser
les revenus du travail nous voulons une
chose qu'à nouveau en France travailler
paye et soit enfin reconnu la valeur
travail c'est la valeur de la droite
française
alors il faudra du courage
le courage de dire qu'on ne peut pas
continuer à avoir des retraités qui ont
travaillé toute leur vie et qui
finissent avec des retraites de misère
alors que dans le même temps des
étrangers qui arrivent dans notre pays
accède à notre sécurité sociale sans
même avoir cotisé si on vient en France
et pour travailler et non pour profiter
des prestations sociales le courage de
dire François comme tu l'as fait qu'en
matière de terrorisme le laxisme c'est
fini et que quand un djihadiste part en
Syrie c'est un aller sans retour parce
qu'ils n'ont plus rien à faire dans un
pays qu'ils ont trahi
le courage enfin de ne plus rien céder
face à un islam radical qui veut nous
dicter sa loi nous défendrons nos
racines toutes nos racines depuis les
racines chrétiennes François jusqu'à
celle de la Révolution française
la France mes amis c'est une belle
histoire la France est un grand pays et
nous ne renoncerons jamais à ce que nous
sommes ce n'est pas à la République de
s'adapter à celui qui vient de
l'étranger c'est à l'étranger de
s'adapter à la République française
et la dernière condition de la victoire
c'est celle que vous montrez maintenant
c'est l'envie c'est la passion c'est
l'enthousiasme vous êtes les
républicains alors dressez-vous que
votre voix résonne que notre
enthousiasme se lève et qu'il ne
s'arrête plus jusqu'à ce que nous ayons
chassé les socialistes et remis la
France la tête à l'endroit vive la
France et vive la république
merci Laurent
je voudrais saluer maintenant de
nouveaux candidats législatifs Pascal
mourut dans le Gard Léa Boyer dans le
Gard également
Laurence azena goujon pour les Français
de l'étranger je voudrais saluer Eric
sobat pour les Pyrénées-Orientales
atlantiques pardon
Ian Boca pour le Territoire de Belfort
myder arosteghi pour les
Pyrénées-Atlantiques également Barbara
Neto pour le Gers et Sylvie Durruti
également pour les Pyrénées-Atlantiques
vous avez tout notre soutien
je voudrais saluer la présence de
l'ancien Premier ministre Édouard
Balladur et
je vais passer la parole
à Bruno Retailleau président du groupe
des Républicains au Sénat président du
Conseil régional des Pays de la Loire
[Applaudissements]
mes chers amis mon cher François
nous sommes réunis en famille pour
Conseil national qui est un peu
particulier
c'est le premier conseil national après
les primaires
et ce sera le dernier conseil national
avec la mère des batailles juste avant
les présidentielles
c'est un conseil national un peu
particulier donc
qui a des allures de veiller d'armes
qui a des allures même d'un conseil de
guerre parce que à l'extérieur d'ici au
delà de ces murs et de cette salle vous
le savez bien et vous les avez entendus
les critiques les balles fusent dans
tous les sens
elles viennent bien sûr du système un
système qui a totalement
ignoré François Fillon pendant les
primaires alors évidemment ce système se
déchaîne
mais ces tirs croisés viennent aussi
d'autres camps de plusieurs camps
ces tirs croisés d'abord viennent d'un
camp
ils viennent de ces faux jumeaux c'est
faux jumeaux que sont la gauche et le
Front national faux jumeaux bien sûr
parce que je ne les confonds pas bien
sûr que ce ne sont pas les mêmes mais
écoutez les mots qu'ils utilisent
écoutez leurs expressions ce sont les
mêmes les mêmes outrances les mêmes
caricatures brutalité violence pour un
peu François Fillon serait à la fois
responsable des diplets d’égypte de la
chute de Rome et très prochainement de
l'Apocalypse oui outrance
outrance mais aussi un posture ces
gens-là
proclame tout haut disent qu'ils veulent
faire campagne qu'ils agissent au nom du
peuple en réalité leur projet leur
campagne c'est sur le dos du peuple
qu'il la font quel est le bilan social
de la gauche qu'est-ce que la gauche a
apporté aux Français les plus fragiles
si ce n'est plus d'un million de
chômeurs
si c'était une pauvreté plus grande
encore
qu'au début de ce quinquennat si ce
n'est une chute du pouvoir d'achat un
institut love ce qui n'est pas marqué à
droite qui est plutôt marqué ailleurs
vous a révélé contre 2012 et 2016 et
français avaient perdu près de 600 euros
par an voilà le bilan social de la
gauche voilà cette gauche qui
méthodiquement à attaquer l'école oui
c'est Vincent Peillon qui voulait
arracher au déterminisme familial les
enfants de l'école voilà cette gauche
qui a attaqué la famille bien sûr avec
la loi Taubira qui l'a attaqué aussi
avec le cœur de la République l'autorité
de l'État l'autorité de la loi voilà le
bilan de la gauche et celui du Front
national
quand Marine Le Pen proclame qu'elle est
candidate du peuple de France
ça signifie quoi de faire campagne pour
le peuple en trompant le peuple
en trompant le peuple en leur disant que
les Français les plus faibles pourront
s'enrichir si la France quitte l'euro
en leur disant qu'on peut continuer à
travailler moins que tous les autres
peuples européens et qu'à ce moment-là
on va s'en tirer grâce à cette molette à
cette facilité voilà Monsieur Madame
Marine Le Pen sans doute d'ailleurs que
Marine Le Pen vous laisse adresser au
peuple en allant aux États-Unis en
restant sur le pas de la porte de
l'histoire de la Trump Tower elle
désirait tant se faire prendre en photo
sous les ordres de cette tour
entourée du meuble de ces meubles et de
ce marbre de Carrare voilà Marine Le Pen
tous ceux et celles qui ont fait
campagne ou régional se souviennent
d'ailleurs que cette cirrh croisée nous
les avons endurées de la gauche et de la
droite et d'ailleurs que constatons
aujourd'hui que Monsieur Mélenchon
dit que Monsieur Philippot fait du
plagiat et que d'ailleurs Marine Le Pen
n'utilise pas seulement
la voix les expressions et les paroles
de la gauche elle reprend même jusqu'à
l'emblème du Parti socialiste jusqu'à la
rose voilà c'est prouvé Marine Le Pen a
besoin du système pour prospérer nous
dénoncerons cette imposture ces
imposture voilà pour les faux jumeaux
mais il y a aussi
à côté de ce camp là
il y a aussi un autre camp celui des
faux amis
faux amis avec Emmanuel Macron Emmanuel
Macron souriant l'ami tout le monde ni
de droite et ni de gauche le candidat du
ni pour ni contre bien au contraire de
tout à la fois
mais en réalité se faux amis il est bien
sûr vis-à-vis du président de la
République il en a été le fossoyeur de
sa candidature alors qu'il en est le
digne est pur héritier il est
co-responsable bien sûr du matraquage
fiscal il a été l'inspirateur de l'échec
économique il était le ministre de
l'Économie et jusqu'au TIC de
comportement il copie son modèle
François Hollande parce que la
contradiction hier contre les camps 35
heures contre l'ISF aujourd'hui on sait
plus où le flou aussi lorsqu'il veut
faire plus de 100 milliards d'euros de
dépenses publiques on lui dit ben écoute
chiche mon gars mais comment tu fais il
faut s'expliquer le peuple de France a
le droit à la vérité donc vous voyez que
c'est quand et faux amis c'est quand des
vrais faux jumeaux c'est le même camp
c'est le camp des bonimenteurs c'est le
camp de tous ceux qui depuis des années
ont voulu parler à la France on la
segmentant en faisant du marketing
politique en oubliant les convictions en
oubliant les colonnes vertébrales des
références en face nous avons un
candidat nous avons François Fillon il
est le candidat de la vérité parce que
j'ai une certitude qui est en même temps
une conviction que vous partagez j'en
suis sûr les Français en ont assez des
fausses promesses et des vrais
renoncements et pour ceux qui nous
concerne pour ce qui nous concerne nous
qui représentons la grande famille
politique de la droite les républicains
il y a aussi un message dans la victoire
de François aux primaires les Français
en ont aussi assez des petits
renoncements les Français en ont assez
d'une droite qui trop souvent dès que la
gauche montait le temps et la gauche est
en train de monter le ton pour nous
faire oublier son bilan c'est tout juste
d’ailleurs si il ne voudrait pas faire
de François Fillon l'ancien président de
la République et bien rappelez-vous une
seule chose les Français de droite on en
marre de cette droite qui passe son
temps à raser les murs de cette droite
qui passe son temps à baisser la tête
dès que la gauche hausse le ton ça n'est
pas notre identité politique
et bien oui mes chers amis aux côtés de
François nous sommes pour la liberté la
liberté pour valoriser le travail
l'effort le mérite pour tous ceux qui
entreprennent en France oui avec
François nous sommes pour l'autorité
l'autorité de l'État l'autorité de la
loi républicaine contre les
corporatismes syndicaux ou autres contre
le communautarisme jamais nous
n'accepterons la soumission de la France
ça n'est pas non plus notre ADN nous
voulons l'autorité de l'État parce que
la France est une nation qu'elle est
indivisible et bien sûr nous voulons
aussi une droite qui s'assume qui assume
des valeurs qui assument des convictions
quand madame Taubira disait que son
texte était un changement de
civilisation et bien si vous vous êtes
attachés à notre civilisation alors vous
concevez aussi qu'il ne peut pas y avoir
de droit à l'enfant il n'y a que des
droits de l'enfant
alors bien sûr mes chers amis ne vous
effrayez pas c'est totalement normal que
nous soyons au centre des critiques et
c'est même rassurant que le système se
défendent c'est très bien et c'est un
atout pour François Fillon simplement
j'appelle ici et là ceux des notes non
pas à dépasser la diversité mais la
diversité n'a de sens que si elle est
orientée vers un projet collectif et
vers la victoire pas pour nous pas pour
le parti mes chers amis mais pour la
France et l'idée qu'on s'en fait qui est
une idée trop haute alors je vous le dis
autour de François Fillon avec François
Fillon c'est ce chemin de vérité qui va
nous permettre de faire se lever une
nouvelle espérance française partout en
France c'est grâce à ce chemin de vérité
que nous allons enfin pouvoir relever
les deux grands défis le défi du
déclassement économique pour que chaque
Français vivent des fruits de leur
travail pour que chaque famille
française suivi espérer pour ses propres
enfants un sort meilleur et puis en même
temps la dépossession culturelle
identitaire si nous voulons demain faire
des réformes il faut que les Français
redeviennent un peuple au-delà d'une
juxtaposition d'individu d'un archipel
de communauté et il redeviendront un
peuple animé d'une volonté collective si
on ne leur dit pas que notre projet pour
la France ça n'est que la France
devienne un carrefour anonyme du village
global ça ce sont les socialistes et
Monsieur Macron évidemment les Français
veulent que l'on garantissent que la
France restera une nation une grande
nation avec des droits des droits pour
le peuple français le premier de ses
droits c'est le droit à la continuité
historique
l'autre droit c'est ce droit à se
définir dans sa propre identité et c'est
une évidence ceux qui viennent chez nous
doivent s'adapter à notre mode de vie à
nos lois il faudra toujours rester
implacable évidemment
mes chers amis
c'est avec et autour de François que
nous allons nous rassembler pour la mère
des grandes batailles la présidentielle
autour de François nous allons porter ce
message le message d'un peuple libre
d'un peuple fier d'un peuple souverain
avec sa force d'âme cette force d'âme
qui lui a permis au moment les plus
tragiques de son histoire quand la
France dégringolait de relever le
drapeau français de relever cette fierté
française de dire non à tous ceux qui
voulaient capituler de dire non à tous
ceux qui voulaient reculer et bien avec
François nous ne reculerons pas nous ne
capitulerons pas parce que vous portez
dans chacun de vos cœurs de français
cette espérance française vous êtes mes
chers amis les sentinelles d'un combat
qui a commencé qui est le combat pour la
France pour l'Espérance française alors
autour de François Fillon nous nous
rassemblons aujourd'hui et demain vive
la République française et vive la
France
merci Bruno
j'appelle maintenant Christian Jacob le
président de notre groupe parlementaire
à l'Assemblée nationale
et je salue l'arrivée de Nathalie
Kosciusko-Morizet
bien mes chers amis ça fait plaisir
effectivement d'autres l'ont dit avant
moi cette tribune de voir notre famille
rassemblée et prête à s'engager sur la
dernière ligne droite celle de
l'élection présidentielle alors vous
avez entendu tous les les commentaires
d'abord ceux qui ont voulu nous faire
croire que François Hollande en
renonçant à se présenter à l'élection
présidentielle avait pris une décision
courageuse qui méritait d'être salué
comme il se doit la réalité c'est tout
simplement c'est une reddition sans
condition c'est une vraie démission
Horace campagne d'ailleurs pouvait-il en
faire autrement et il l'a fait dans
quelles conditions il l'a fait sous les
coups de poignard d'un Premier ministre
qui porte aujourd'hui d'ailleurs tout le
poids de sa trahison dans cette campagne
des primaires
ils ont mes chers amis abîmer nos
institutions en allant jusqu'à nommer un
Premier ministre qui est là pour 5 mois
pour avec pour seul mission de fermer
les lumières ou de tenter de repeindre
en rose un bilan qui est noir pour la
France
et je voudrais dire un mot à propos de
Monsieur Cazeneuve il faut pas oublier
ce qu'il est il est celui qui a laissé
faire les nuits debout place de la
République et un peu partout en France
il est celui
qui a laissé faire les actes odieux
contre l'hôpital Necker
il est celui qui a mis à peine arrivé à
Matignon un genou à terre devant les
anarchistes à Notre-Dame-des-Landes il
est celui qui a refusé avec dédain avec
mépris toutes les propositions ou la
plupart des propositions que nous avons
fait pour lutter contre le terrorisme
djihadiste
et ce qui se termine aujourd'hui pour
les socialistes par une véritable
Bérézina a commencé ne l'oublions pas
par les mensonges indignes à l'occasion
de la présidentielle les Français y ont
cru et l'enjeu pour nous l'enjeu il est
aujourd'hui
d'expliquer que et de faire en sorte que
nos compatriotes entendent comprennent
et adhèrent un discours de vérité et ce
discours de vérité c'est le tien
François c'est le discours que tu portes
aujourd'hui en notre nom
ce discours vous savez il va être
difficile à faire passer parce qu'il
faut l'assumer et pour cela nous avons
effectivement besoin que toute notre
famille soit rassemblée qu'elle soit
Unies et ce conseil national et ce
symbole aujourd'hui quel qui était nos
choix au primaire nous sommes unis nous
sommes rassemblés nous sommes à tes
côtés François
le bilan de la gauche rappelons-le là
aussi le bilan de la gauche c'est
d'abord un million 150 000 chômeurs
toutes catégories confondues de plus en
4 ans et demi c'est ça leur bilan c'est
ensuite la bombe à retardement du
chômage des jeunes et puis c'est aussi
l'apprentissage qui a été sacrifié nous
l'avons souvent évoqué à cette à cette
tribune vous avez souvent entendu
défendre l'apprentissage à 14 ans je
continue à le défendre ils ont sacrifié
l'apprentissage sur l'hôtel de leur
doctrine
l'urgence là aussi ça a été dit c'est de
réhabiliter le travail et nous avons un
vrai dilemme avec la gauche sur le
travail pour la gauche le travail est un
mal nécessaire c'est une contrainte pour
nous le travail c'est un élément
d'identité c'est un élément
d'intégration c'est un épanouissement et
c'est là-dessus qu'il faut se battre ce
sont ça les valeurs de la droite c'est
le travail et sa reconnaissance
et pour cela il faudra faire sauter le
verrou des 35 heures le faire sauter
dans le privé le faire sauter dans le
public
la France
continuera à décliner si elle ne
travaille pas plus et ça ça fait aussi
partie du message de vérité que nous
devons avoir le bilan de la gauche c'est
aussi le déficit c'est aussi la dette
c'est aussi le matricaire le matraquage
systématique des classes moyennes la
surconstration de l'impôt la baisse du
quotient familial la mise sous condition
de ressources des allocations familiales
la fiscalisation des complémentaires
santé on a tendance à oublier tout cela
il faut aussi le rappeler à l'occasion
de cette campagne le bilan de la gauche
c'est aussi la confiscation du fruit du
travail à coup de RSA de CMU d'ame de
tiers pays en généralisé et si on ne
l'arrête pas avec le revenu universel
notre devoir demain en application de
ton projet François
c'est de faire en sorte de reconnaître
et de récompenser ceux qui travaillent
ceux qui produisent plus ceux qui
enrichissent la France on ne peut pas en
un mot prendre toujours au même et
donner à ceux qui profitent du système
et il ne faut pas confondre solidarité
assistanat la solidarité c'est une
valeur de droite la solidarité c'est
noble la solidarité c'est notre honneur
l'assistanat ça continue
l'assistanat ça nous conduit à l'échelle
à la déchéance et ça nous conduit à
l'échec et nous devons nous battre
contre l'assistanat et valoriser nos
actions de solidarité
le bilan de la gauche c'est aussi la
case dans l'éducation nationale madame
Belkacem et ses acolytes payant et Hamon
alors ils auront au moins un record je
pense qu'il resteront dans notre
République comme les ministres qui ont
fait qui ont fait fuir le plus d'élèves
du public vers le privé il faudra au
moins le reconnaître cela
ils ont mené avec méthode une politique
sectaire et dogmatique dogmatique sur
les rythmes scolaires dogmatiques sur la
réforme du collège sectaire sur les
programmes notamment en histoire où il
creuse un fossé dangereux entre nos
jeunes et l'histoire de notre pays une
histoire qu'il réécrivent si elle ne
correspond pas à leur valeur de gauche
au moment d'ailleurs où certains tata
compteusement François parce que tu
aurais eu l'outrecuidance de te
revendiquer chrétien
est-ce que l'on acceptera longtemps de
baisser les yeux et de s'excuser d'être
les produits d'une civilisation
judéo-chrétienne d'être les enfants de
l'esprit des Lumières
il est temps de lever les yeux et de
relever la terre
d'avoir le courage d'assumer ce que nous
sommes et ce qu'est la France
enfin le bilan de la gauche
ça n'est pas le bilan de Hollande c'est
le bilan de tous de valse à Macron
demandebourg à sa fin de Taubira à
Cazeneuve ils sont tous cautions
solidaires de ce bilan on ne va pas
rappeler l'affaire Cahuzac ou les
ministres qui est sont devenus
administrativement phobique et puis deux
expressions deux expressions qui ne font
pas oublier
lescendants de François Hollande et les
ouvrières illettrés de Monsieur Macron
vous savez ces deux expressions elles en
disent beaucoup plus long que n'importe
quel discours sur ce que la gauche
penserait réellement du peuple
je ne reviens pas sur le scooter d'un
président complètement inconscient de
ces comportements sur mademoiselle
leonarda sur le secret défense donnés en
pâture aux journalistes le temps de
l'alternance approche le temps de la
rupture profonde le temps d'un
changement qui permet à nouveau à la
France d'être vraiment présidé et d'être
vraiment gouverné
cette France ce sera celle de la
présidence de François Fillon nous
devons aujourd'hui avec lui autour de
lui travailler de toutes nos forces pour
le porter à l'Elysée et pour lui offrir
une majorité forte avec un groupe de
parlementaires
issu des républicains un groupe qui aura
la majorité absolue parce que mes chers
amis moi j'aime tout le monde on accepte
tous les soutiens mais un moment si vous
nous voulons conduire une politique
claire nette sans ambiguïté il faut le
faire sur nos socles notre socle et donc
il faut avoir la majorité absolue chez
les républicains ceux qui veulent nous
rejoindre sur les bienvenus mais c'est
nous qui porterons le projet et c'est à
nous d'avoir la majorité absolue seules
les républicains doivent avoir
et c'est de cette façon mon cher
François que nous mettrons en œuvre ton
projet avec détermination avec courage
et sans trembler vive la France vive la
république
[Applaudissements]
merci mon cher Christian je voudrais
qu'on découvre à nouveau de nouveaux
visages de candidature aux élections
législatives
grâce à ce conseil national où nous
sommes tous réunis j'en ai la conviction
l'efficacité le pragmatisme et la
responsabilités vont bien être au coeur
à présent de la politique pour nos
concitoyens rien n'est impossible si
nous savons nous rassembler avec toutes
nos différences c'est le cœur de mon
engagement alors ce premier conseil
national de l'année et l'occasion pour
nous de nous rassembler autour de
François Fillon avec pour seul but et
seul objectif de le conduire à la
victoire et de lui apporter la majorité
présidentielle nécessaire pour mener à
terme nos réformes les Landes ne sont
plus une terre de mission mais une terre
de conquête pour la droite et le centre
et nous allons le prouver dans les
échéances qui suivent les
présidentielles et les législatives je
me suis engagé auprès des républicains
parce que je crois que nous avons à
restaurer dans notre pays la confiance
l'audace et l'envie de construire
ensemble une nation forte une France
puissante qui a encore beaucoup de
choses à dire au monde ensemble nous
allons créer un large rassemblement
autour de notre candidat François Fillon
et le Conseil national de cette belle
journée doit être le moment fondateur
pour tous nous mettre au service de
notre candidat et faire gagner François
Fillon en mai prochain et lui offrir en
juin une majorité franche une majorité
loyale une majorité claire qui permettra
de faire les réformes dont notre pays a
tant besoin à partir de 2017
et je voudrais saluer ici à la tribune
Mireille de l'Orgerie le candidate dans
l'Aude Franck l'ouvrier candidat en
Loire-Atlantique
Marie-Françoise Nadeau candidate dans
les Landes Manon Laporte candidate en
Seine-Saint-Denis
Nancy Cano candidate dans l'Hérault
Laurence Cristol également dans
l'Hérault et Olivier Capron candidat
dans le Nord vous pouvez les applaudir
et Sonia candidate en Guadeloupe
la parole est à notre secrétaire général
Bernard à coyez
[Applaudissements]
chers François Fillon
cher Luc Châtel président de notre
conseil national Monsieur le Premier
Ministre cher Édouard Balladur Monsieur
le Premier Ministre chers amis
c'est un honneur pour moi de m'adresser
à vous de le faire en tant que
secrétaire général de notre mouvement et
je dois d'abord remercier François
Villon de m'avoir confié cette
responsabilité que j'exerce accompagnée
de mes deux secrétaires généraux
adjoints Gérald davana et Annie genvar
et avec nos deux vices présidents
Laurent Wauquiez et Isabelle le
galénique
je veux aussi saluer très amicalement
chacune et chacun d'entre vous vous mes
amis parlementaires et élus vous cadres
de nos fédérations vous conseillez
nationaux vous candidats et candidate
aux élections législatives des 11 et 18
juin et vous chers militants
républicains de Paris de nos 108
fédérations venus de Paris de toute la
France de la métropole d'outre-mer et
aussi les représentants des Français de
l'étranger
les vins et 27 novembre chez vous
cadres et militants qui avait été les
artisans de cette grande réussite
démocratique qui a été la primaire de la
droite et du centre je veux vous en
remercier c'est aussi la force unique
que constitue notre grande famille des
républicains rassemblant la droite et le
centre qui a permis ce succès cette
famille elle a été la volonté et la
concrétisation de Jacques Chirac en 2002
[Applaudissements]
les républicains
issus de l'UMP notre famille qui doit
tente à son fondateur comme à celui qui
la remise sur pied nos deux amis deux
hommes d'État le premier qui a servi
notre pays avec un dévouement que nul
n'a atteint à la Juppé
le second qui lui aussi s'est donné
totalement à la France dont il a été le
président de la République respecté qui
a protégé notre pays et l'Europe dans
les pires conditions de crise Nicolas
Sarkozy
grâce à votre dévouement
[Applaudissements]
par deux choix
4 millions électeurs de la droite et du
centre ont pu s'exprimer et désigner
très clairement pour l'élection
présidentielle des 23 avril et 7 mai
notre candidat François Fillon
François Fillon choisi par les électeurs
de la primaire comme les prévois nos
statues et donc devenu le président de
notre mouvement François nous te
connaissons je te connais depuis
longtemps nous connaissons tes qualités
humaines de travail de fidélité
d'honnêteté nous connaissons l'homme
politique l'élu l'homme d'État et nous
sommes avec toi derrière le gaulliste
social que tu es
[Applaudissements]
mais si notre candidat
bénéficie ainsi d'un avantage d'une
dynamique importante pour autant la
route est encore longue et piègeuse
jusqu'à l'élection présidentielle
alors que la paix mondiale n'a jamais
été aussi menacé depuis la fin de la
guerre froide
alors que l'Europe trébuche comme jamais
depuis le traité de Rome
tandis que la France est confrontée à
une situation d'une gravité inconnue
depuis la fin de la quatrième République
notre pays a besoin d'un chef d'État à
la hauteur de ses défis angoissants
un homme d'État porteur d'un projet de
véritable rupture pour enfin interrompre
la spirale infernale d'un déclin qui
s'accélère notre pays a besoin d'une
analyse lucide de la situation critique
dans laquelle il se trouve notre pays a
besoin d'un projet courageux de réforme
à la hauteur des défis auxquels nous
sommes confrontés
cette analyse ce projet ils sont portés
par François Fillon le projet de
François Fillon est audacieux porteur de
profonde réforme justement parce que la
France a besoin de réforme et de courage
le projet François Fillon est fondé sur
la vérité car la vérité est toujours
moins violente que le mensonge a priori
nous pourrions sous-estimer le candidat
d'une gauche affaiblie par ses divisions
et fracassées après cinq années de
présidents Hollande un président qui a
été élu en 2012 sur le déni de la crise
mondiale et sur des promesses
mensongères un président qui abandonne
une France confrontée à de multiples
graves crises
économique et social sécuritaire
financière morale et crise politique
mais
sous-estimer la gauche serait une erreur
car en fait le candidat de la gauche
c'est Monsieur Macron monsieur Macron ce
fils par ici de François Hollande dont
il a été l'inspirateur de la
catastrophique politique fiscale et
économique dont il a été le ministre de
l'Économie un ministre dont nous
découvrons l'étendue et la gravité des
erreurs aux dépens des fleurons de notre
industrie
son positionnement politique et son
pitoyable bilan c'est à dire le bilan de
François Hollande monsieur Macron
voudrait faire croire qu'il va sauver
notre pays alors qu'il ne conduit qu'une
opération de marketing politique
mensongère de l'autre côté à l'extrême
droite Madame Le Pen n'en finit pas de
copier le programme économique social et
anti-européen de l'extrême gauche celui
d'un populisme démagogue et dangereux
oui mes chers amis notre responsabilité
est immense car il y a que notre
candidat et son projet pour la France
qui puisse relever le défi national et
international
notre détermination pour faire gagner
François Fillon sera total il n'y a
désormais plus de place pour les états
d'âme
plus de place pour les tergiversations
ou les stratégies personnelles nous n'en
n'avons pas le droit nos compatriotes ne
le méritent pas ils nous le feraient
payer très cher à tous et pour longtemps
mes chers amis je vous appelle donc tous
à cette unité conditions première de la
victoire je n'ai pas en allant critiquer
publiquement le programme de notre
candidat en prétendant la main sur le
cœur qu'il faut juste en changer sur tel
ou tel point je n'ai pas en persistant à
faire de la fin du cumul des mandats un
sujet aussi important que la situation
de la France ce n'est pas ainsi que nous
réussirons à atteindre notre objectif la
victoire une victoire un objectif que
nous partageons tous et que nous devons
tous partager
[Applaudissements]
quand on a une suggestion à faire à
notre candidat qui est ici c'est à lui
que nous la faisons pas devant un micro
c'est cela qui différencie l'action
individuelle au service d'une stratégie
personnelle de l'intérêt collectif au
service de notre candidat de ces
millions de Français qui nous ont fait
confiance au service de notre pays
à chaque fois qu'ils entendent nos voix
dissonantes il ne tout comprennent pas
nos compatriotes c'est cela qui peut
mettre à mal une dynamique de campagne
c'est aussi cela qui éloigne de nous nos
propres électeurs c'est cela qui ruine
la crédibilité des responsables
politiques et nourrit l'abstention et
les votes protestataires chers amis vous
qui êtes le cœur battant de notre
famille politique vous l'avez compris
votre engagement irréprochable est
totale dans la campagne de François
Fillon sera décisif la victoire le 7 mai
de notre candidat dépend aussi de nous
je compte sur vous pour que François
Fillon devienne le 8ème président de la
Cinquième République et qui a de nouveau
vive la France
et maintenant j'ai le plaisir de laisser
la parole à nouveau
de laisser la parole à Luc chapelle Luc
Chatel est le président de notre conseil
national c'est un homme dont nous
apprécions tous les qualités chez
l'artisan du rassemblement c'est celui
qui avec toute sa loyauté et son ardeur
conduit notre conseil national un
soutien unanime à François Fillon
mes amis dans 100 jours les Français
éliront leur président de la République
et sous la Cinquième République
l'élection présidentielle
c'est le point d'orgue de notre
engagement
bien sûr gagner les élections
municipales
c'est enthousiasmant cher Florence
Berthoud maire du cinquième
arrondissement qui nous accueille et que
nous pouvons applaudir
bien sûr conquérir un département c'est
un vrai défi cher Edouard
bien sûr ma chère Valérie vous pouvez
l'applaudir aussi
bien sûr ma chère Valérie
remporté une région c'est un fait
d'armes politique
mais gagner l'élection présidentielle
c'est notre raison d'être c'est ce qui
guide notre engagement c'est une
expérience inouïe dans nos vies de
militants
souvenez-vous de l'enthousiasme qui a
accompagné l'élection de Nicolas Sarkozy
en 2007
souvenez-vous de la ferveur de
l'élection de Jacques Chirac en 95 en
remontant plus loin mon cher Jean-Pierre
souvenons-nous la dynamique qui avait
été créée par Giscard devant la jeunesse
en 74 et bien mes chers amis mon cher
François la victoire à l'élection
présidentielle ça devra d'abord être
celle de nos valeurs ça devrait être
celle de nos idées ça devrait être le
triomphe des convictions pour lesquelles
chaque jour nous nous battons et si le
Parlement de notre parti est aujourd'hui
rassemblée derrière toi c'est parce que
nous te faisons confiance pour défendre
ses convictions et pour les incarner
il ne peut y avoir de place dans les
prochaines semaines pour la boudrie pour
la rancune pour les petits calculs
personnels nous avons pour un certain
d'entre nous nos fidélités et je peux en
témoigner mon cher François tu ne nous a
jamais demandé d'y renoncer mais mes
amis les choses sont claires aujourd'hui
nous sommes rassemblés derrière François
Fillon pour le faire gagner et pour
faire gagner nos idées
à mon sens cette élection présidentielle
et sans doute celle de la dernière
chance de la dernière chance pour la
France
d'accéder à ce nouveau monde qui nous
tend les bras et auquel nous nous
évertions à tourner le dos depuis trop
longtemps
sans cette victoire la France se
condamne à rester éternellement sur le
seuil de ce nouveau monde à mourir
déclassé asphyxié dans l'antichambre du
21e siècle a subir telle une coquille de
noix ballottée par les tempêtes les
crises politiques
géopolitiques économique un être fier
que de son passé abandonnant son destin
et celui des Français dans les mains du
hasard ou de l'incertitude
dans le monde du 21e siècle mes amis il
n'y a pas de place qui est garantie rien
n'est offert personne ne nous attend on
peut émerger comme on peut disparaître
tout est à conquérir à force de
réactivité à force d'agilité à force
d'imagination à force de créativité et
bien il est grand temps d'ouvrir sur ce
nouveau monde les yeux enfin un monde
fascinant un monde où le projet
technique scientifique et désormais
exponentielle songer mes chers amis que
dans les 10 prochaines années moins de
deux quinquennats mon cher François la
connaissance mondiale va doubler oui
l'humanité va produire plus de
connaissances dans les 10 prochaines
années qu'elle n'en a produit au cours
de ces 7000 premières années de son
histoire
[Musique]
c'est parce que je considère que
l'élection présidentielle c'est pas
uniquement la question de savoir si on
va réserver 40 ou 50 conception à l'UDI
c'est pas uniquement la question de
savoir si Macron est de droite ou de
gauche non la question c'est de savoir
si la France elle est capable d'entrer
dans ce nouveau monde et bien oui mes
chers amis elle sera capable de rentrer
dans ce nouveau monde avec un programme
audacieux avec un programme réformateur
avec le programme de François Fillon
où on est la France après cinq années de
socialisme après cinq années de François
Hollande la France elle se réjouit
triomphalement d'être le premier pays au
monde à avoir inventé le droit à la
déconnexion la déconnexion je vais vous
dire c'est ce qui illustre finalement
assez bien le mandat de François
Hollande et bien le programme de
François Fillon ton programme mon cher
François il doit permettre
en disant tu le dis régulièrement de
faire de la France la première puissance
économique d'Europe c'est possible mes
amis c'est possible en faisant ce qu'on
fait nos voisins en commençant chercher
le caresse par réduire massivement la
dépense publique oui nous devons réduire
la dépense publique pas pour faire
plaisir à Bruxelles pas par dogme tout
simplement pour enlever le sac de plomb
qui pèse sur tous les créateurs de ce
pays on ne peut pas continuer à être les
champions des dépenses publiques en y
consacrant 57% de notre création de
richesse parce que si on est les
champions de la dépense publique on est
forcément les champions des impôts et
des taxes pour les financer avec 45% du
produit intérieur brut si vous commencez
le match dans la compétition qui nous
oppose à l'Allemagne alors qu'on vous
prélève 45% de votre richesse et bien
vous avez aucune chance de le gagner
face à votre concurrence allemande qui
lui à qui on va prélever
36%, 9 points d'écart et bien forcément
comme on disait dans les années 80 en
football c'est l'Allemagne qui gagne à
la fin et bien moi je veux qu'on montre
maintenant que c'est plus l'Allemagne
qui gagne à la fin que nous allons
réformer notre économie que nous allons
baisser la dépense publique et que nous
allons revenir dans le jeu
j'entends dire ici ou là ça n'est pas
possible de réduire la dépense publique
de 100 milliards d'euros mais enfin
faisons ensemble un rapide calcul mes
amis le somme la somme de la dépense
publique en France c'est 1200 milliards
d'euros 100 milliards d'économies en 5
ans c'est 20 milliards d'économies par
an 20 milliards sur 1200
1,6%
quelle est l'entreprise
quel est le ménage ici dans la salle qui
n'est pas capable de réaliser 1,6%
d'économie par an ouvrons les yeux mes
amis
j'entendais ça va être difficile de
supprimer 500 000 emplois de
fonctionnaires j'aurais juste rappeler
un chiffre en 30 ans le nombre de
fonctionnaires dans notre pays a
augmenté de 36%. est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que la France est news
administrée aujourd'hui elle a augmenté
de 36% ce nombre alors que la population
augmentait en parallèle de 18%. la
France a aujourd'hui 80 fonctionnaires
pour 1000 habitants l'Allemagne 1000 la
Grande-Bretagne 45 et si on supprime ce
que prévoit le programme de François
Fillon 500 000 postes de fonctionnaires
il y en aura en 2022 plus qu'il y en
avait quand Lionel Jospin était premier
ministre alors ouvrons les yeux mes amis
assez de désinformation de grâce
oui François
tu as raison de parler de plein emploi
c'est possible d'autres l'ont fait
autour de nous et quand j'entends là
encore certains dire
sur la lutte contre le chômage on a tout
essayé les amis on a tout essayé sur ce
qui marche on a tout essayé sauf ce qui
a réussi ailleurs en Allemagne en
Grande-Bretagne aux États-Unis nous
réussirons comme en baissant les charges
des entreprises pour abaisser le coût du
travail sur tous les niveaux de salaire
pas uniquement sur le SMIC comme tu as
voulu dans ton programme en supprimant
les seuils qui ont fait cette absurdité
qu'il y a deux fois et demi plus
d'entreprises de 49 salariés que de 50
salariés en libérant les emplois à
domicile en ramenant la fiscalité sur le
capital à la moyenne européenne taxé le
capital au niveau du travail ça a été la
plus grande bêtise de François Hollande
regardez les résultats le nombre
d'exilés fiscal en France a été
multipliée par quatre en cinq ans dix
mille entrepreneurs nous ont quitté pour
aller créer ailleurs pour aller
reprendre ailleurs nous devons leur
tendre la main ça passe par une réforme
fiscale profonde qui attire les
investisseurs qui attirent les capitaux
moins de riches avec François Hollande
et dans le même temps plus de pauvres
jamais le nombre de bénéficiaires au
minimum avait été aussi important il a
cessé augmenter depuis 2012 et là mes
amis nous touchons une différence
majeure entre les socialistes et nous
ils veulent qui est moins de riches nous
on veut témoigne pauvre c'est ça la
différence entre la droite et la gauche
nous remettrons en ordre notre pays nous
remettrons la France dans la course
grâce à de l'audace grâce à la vérité
grâce à de la modernité mais de grâce
mes amis quand j'entends parler
y compris dans nos propres rangs de sang
de larmes d'austérité de purge je
m'étrangle ouvrez les yeux là aussi mes
chers amis quand on a 70 milliards de
déficits c'est-à-dire pas trois et demi
pour cent mais 20% au regard de notre
dépense alors que l'Allemagne elle est
en excédent budgétaire quand on emprunte
chaque mois pour rembourser ses propres
emprunts et pour payer ses
fonctionnaires quand on a 2000 milliards
de dettes quand on est le pays qui
déplace le plus et le pays qui prélève
le plus qui fonctionne le plus parlé de
Kurdes érité mes amis c'est tout
simplement abject ne tombons pas dans le
piège de nos adversaires
utilisez les mots de la gauche c'est
déjà commencé à céder à leur idéologie
vous les avez vu vous les avez vu jeudi
soir j'imagine on nous annonçait la
primaire de la batte vous savez ce que
c'est la baffe la belle alliance
populaire bah écoutez moi j'ai surtout
vu la primaire du DAB le distributeur
automatique de billets
ils auraient dû changer leur nom ils
auraient dû appeler ça qui veut dépenser
des milliards vous avez entendu
Benoît Hamon et propose un revenu
universel dont le coût annuel est égal
au budget de l'État le coût annuel est
égal au budget de l'État remarqué il est
assez cohérent Benoît Hamon finalement
il a été ministre de l'éducation
nationale le temps des grandes vacances
il ne croit pas au travail et bien il
propose tout simplement de les payer
pendant les vacances
Arnaud Montebourg il veut taxer les
banques on n'y avait pas pensé je dois
dire ça c'est typiquement le
raisonnement socialiste ils ont un
problème avec la CDD on taxe les CDD
résultat il y a plus de CDD ils ont un
problème avec le temps partiel on taxe
autant partiel résultat il y a plus de
temps partiel ils ont un problème avec
les stages on taxe les stages résultats
il y a plus de stage les socialistes
sont addicts à la taxation on a notre
philosophe qui revient de Suisse ça vous
rappelle rien un philosophe qui revient
de Suisse
Vincent payant se prend pour Rousseau
oui c'est vrai qu'il a tout du rêveur
solitaire Vincent payant mais quand on
l'écoute sur le voile ou sur la laïcité
et bien c'est plutôt les délires du
promeneur solitaire quant à Manuel Valls
Manuel Valls il est extraordinaire vous
avez remarqué
c'est comme les tarifs du gaz et de
l'électricité il a changé le 1er janvier
2017 mais il a changé pas un peu il
était contre les 35 heures et pour il
était contre l'ISF il pour il était pour
le 49-3 il est contre la vérité c'est
qu'on s'est plus très bien à quoi il
fonctionne on avale mais on a perdu le
manuel manifestement
quand je pense mes chers amis que
François Hollande nous parler
d'alignement de planètes et bien comme
vous jeudi soir j'ai surtout vu beaucoup
de vieilles lunes socialistes la
différence entre eux et nous mes amis
c'est que nous nous voyons le monde tel
qu'il est nous nous voyons la France
déclinée nous voyons la France
s'enfoncer et la force de ta candidature
mon cher François c'est d'avoir fait un
diagnostic juste sur la situation du
pays un diagnostic sans concession un
constat lucide sur la réalité du monde
faisons en sorte qu'en votant pour
François Fillon et nous fasse entrer
dans ce nouveau monde qui nous tend les
bras mes chers amis candidats au
législatives tout va être à réinventer
notre relation au travail à la santé au
monde à la vie
jamais sans doute la politique n'aura
été aussi passionnante mes amis c'est la
droite aujourd'hui qui incarne la
modernité c'est la garde la droite qui
va l'incarner à travers le profil de nos
candidats aux élections législatives
alors François nous sommes là à tes
côtés pour que tu défendes ces valeurs
nous sommes là à tes côtés pour que tu
nous donnes les clés de ce nouveau monde
mais nous sommes là surtout pour que tu
nous mènes à la victoire vive la
république et vive la France
[Applaudissements]
mes amis je voudrais appeler notre
ancien Premier ministre ancien président
du Conseil national qu'il a présidé avec
brio Jean-Pierre Raffard
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît pour que tout le monde
puisse entendre les propos de
Jean-Pierre Raffarin et des différents
orateurs je vous demanderai soit de
sortir pour discuter soit de nous
écouter merci
[Musique]
bonjour
vous avez ce qu'il vous faut comme
discours aujourd'hui
ça tombe bien c'est le dernier jour à
partir de demain il y en a plus qu'un ça
nous rassemble et c'est celui de
François alors profitez-en à partir de
demain nous sommes tous rassemblés dans
le même discours celui que porte
François pour nous devant les Français
François Fillon a inventé le théorème de
la primaire très franchement mon cher
François je le connaissais pas mais je
l'ai bien perçu trace ta route et ne te
laisse pas ta route tracée par les
autres tu nous as montré ton chemin
difficile au début tu as tracé avec des
terminations et conviction et tu as
obtenu le soutien massif des électeurs
de droite mais aussi les électeurs du
centre
franchement
vous pouvez être fier de vous on peut
être fier de nous c’était quand même pas
évident on a déjà joué dans le passé
entre l'éthique de conduction et
l'éthique de responsabilité et il nous
arrête avec la conviction l'emporta sur
la responsabilité et réciproquement là
on a fait une vraie campagne de
conviction chacun défendu ses idées et
maintenant globalement nous assumons
l'éthique de responsabilité c'est le
respect de la démocratie le résultat est
un contestable et tous ceux qui comme
nous ont l'ADN démocratique sont
aujourd'hui rassemblés derrière François
pour la France
je pense que
dans une démarche
collective le courage c'est la loyauté
je ne vois pas de courage dans la
dissidence je vois plutôt une faute et
je vois un mensonge au fond la
dissidence cache la solitude derrière
l'ambition nous nous portons un
rassemblement que nous avons
collectivement construit et que nos
électeurs ont massivement approuvé c'est
pour ça que nous sommes rassemblés la
droite et le centre dans ce deuxième
route de campagne électorale qui sera
évidemment pour le pays décisif je veux
adresser un message de respect et
d'affection pour Alain Juppé et pour
Nicolas Sarkozy et pour tous ceux qui se
sont engagés dans ce débat
qui nous a permis aujourd'hui d'être
rassemblé grâce aux efforts des uns et
des autres et notamment à la qualité de
l'organisation de ce débat interne nous
sommes naturellement qu'une partie de
l'électorat de François check-électorat
est beaucoup plus large mais nous en
sommes le visage le plus observé le plus
étudié et donc nous avons une
responsabilité particulière
nos humeurs peuvent être des erreurs
nous sommes observés scrutés et nous
sommes ce visage d'un électorat qui doit
être déterminé mobiliser mais
fondamentalement responsable
dans ce contexte là
mesurons la gravité de la situation nous
sommes pas dans une compétition dans un
match de foot on va célébrer un
vainqueur et que on va verser quelques
larmes dans le camp des perdants non
nous sommes aujourd'hui dans un monde
très dangereux
depuis que je fais de la politique
depuis que je m'intéresse aux affaires
du monde en politique étrangère
notamment je n'ai jamais vu la situation
internationale aussi dégradée quand vous
regardez ce qui se passe en mer de Chine
en Asie nos inquiétudes sont fortes on
est content de vendre des sous-marins
aux Australiens mais vous croyez que si
les Australiens ils achètent des
sous-marins c'est qu'ils sont
tranquilles de la situation tout autour
d'eux quand on voit l'armement
aujourd'hui monté nous sommes fiers
d'avoir une industrie de l'armement
puissante mais on voit que cet armement
aujourd'hui révèle des dangerosités
terribles dans le monde quand on voit
tous ceux qui se passe aujourd'hui en
Russie où Monsieur Poutine va souvent à
l'extérieur chercher les satisfactions
qu'il ne peut pas donner à son peuple à
l'intérieur et on voit le nationalisme
se développer avec des tensions Inter
très forte mais en même temps une
mobilisation extérieure quelque peu
belliqueuse quand nous voyons l'Iran
aujourd'hui avec ces nouvelles ambitions
cette tension avec l'Arabie Saoudite
quand nous voyons tous ceux qui se passe
au Levant et même quand nous gagnons des
positions au Levant que font les
djihadistes que nous chassons soit ils
veulent revenir chez nous soit ils s'en
vont en Libye à la porte de ce pays de
ce peuple frère que le peuple tunisien
était un objectif majeur pour l'État
islamique pour porter atteinte à cette
jeune démocratie voisine à nos
frontières et si la Tunisie fléchissait
et si l’algérie était contaminé imaginez
la situation dans laquelle serait
aujourd'hui et notre continent européen
et notre nation française quand on
regarde ce monde quand vous regardez ce
qui s'est passé aujourd'hui
et dans ces périodes récentes autour du
brexit quand vous voyez cette campagne
américaine aujourd'hui nous verrons bien
ce que fera monsieur Trump mais il y
avait trois bonnes nouvelles en 2016 sur
le plan international je n'envoyais que
trois
certes la COP 21 qui a été bien vendu en
France mais qui est quand même un accord
international de première importance
l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien et
puis il arrivait de gouttérès à l'ONU
pour renforcer le multilatéral avec un
homme de qualité portugais européen
compétent et bien monsieur Trump il va
remettre en cause les deux accords et
qu'on s'exciter l'action bilatérale de
l'ONU dans ce monde dangereux l'élection
présidentielle française et quelque
chose de grave chers amis ce n'est pas
un combat de spectacle c'est l'avenir de
nos enfants jamais le monde a autant
parlé de guerre jamais le monde pourtant
réarmé jamais les états puissances non
conduit autant de stratégie individuelle
et menaçante dans ce contexte François
tu le sais mieux que quiconque il nous
faut un président fort un président de
sang-froid un président qui veut parler
à tout le monde un président qui sait
faire
la différence entre les colères et les
humeurs et les lignes stratégiques de
notre pays dans ce contexte-là de
gravité on ne peut pas donner les reines
de notre pays à quelqu'un qui n'a pas la
solidité la profondeur de pensée le
calme de la sérénité c'est franchement
c'est pas pour nous c'est pas pour nous
c'est pas à nous qu'il faut penser dans
ces circonstances c'est à nos enfants à
l'avenir de ce pays qui peut très bien
connaître des heures sombres car le plus
semble n'est jamais éliminé
définitivement dans ce contexte là un
président fort un président comme disait
Victor Hugo dans Hernani qui soit une
force qui va et qui sait où elle va
cette force elle va on le sait bien dans
ton projet François dans trois
directions principales il faut débloquer
l'économie française je n'y reviens pas
nous en avons beaucoup parlé mais il est
clair que la grande ambition sociale de
notre combat c'est l'emploi il ne peut y
avoir de rêves sociaux de vision sociale
d'ambition sociale avec le chômage qui
augmente c'est l'emploi la première de
ses ambitions et c'est pour ça qu'il
nous faut libérer l'énergie
entrepreneuriale c'est pour ça qu'il
nous faut moins de dépenses publiques et
plus d'initiative privé et c'est pour ça
qu'il faut soutenir toutes les
initiatives et notamment celle que tu
allais saluer des jeunes parce que
finalement une des rares bon NES
nouvelles de notre économie ce sont tous
ces jeunes créateurs en France et
ailleurs tous ces jeunes ingénieurs qui
valorisent notre formation et qui
aujourd'hui sont porteur d'une valeur
d'avenir pour le pays c'est à eux que
nous devons faire confiance à condition
que nous soyons capables de libérer leur
énergie et de faire confiance alors
caractère
débloquer l'économie française
évidemment mais deuxièmement refonder
cette société de valeur qui doit être la
société française celle de l'humanisme
français avec laquelle nous sommes tous
engagés ça a été dit ici j'avais très
vite mais non à la société des excuses
non la société de l'irresponsabilité non
à la société de l'anonymat nous voulons
une société vivante une société qui
respecte la personne une société qui
considère qu'il y a dans la personne
quelque chose de sacré qu'il y a en nous
des choses qui sont plus grandes que
nous et c'est pour ça que notre dignité
doit être partout respecter et c'est
pour ça que nous avons la vraie égalité
l'égalité de la dignité fondée sur notre
responsabilité nous pouvons bien nous
comporter nous pouvons mal nous
comporter c'est notre responsabilité et
c'est cette responsabilité qu'il a
source de notre dignité dans ce contexte
là ces valeurs sont importantes pour
nous de la fraternité de la cohésion de
la responsabilité et de l'engagement et
tout ceci avec des fortes volontés y
compris sur la laïcité nous sommes
engagés dans un combat pour la laïcité
mais ça nous empêche pas évidemment de
dire que nous sommes chrétiens pour ceux
qui le sont et que d'être fier de l'air
et ma foi les chemins de Saint-Jacques
de Compostelle va bien la Roche de
Solutré on peut parler de nos idées mais
jamais jamais nous ne ferons de la
religion un projet politique ce n'est
pas dans la religion que nous trouvons
les sources du comportement politique
nous y trouvons des sources de
comportement personnels des valeurs qui
nous conduisent mais qui ne doivent pas
conduire la société c'est la République
qui conduit la société c'est dans ces
conditions là avec respect
des autres mais un respect dans la
première des valeurs c'est d'être
réciproque je te respecte mais il faut
que tu me respectes y compris dans mon
entité la plus profonde notre humanisme
chers amis ce n'est pas un humanisme
conservateur quand on est attaché à la
vraie valeur à la valeur de la personne
de ce qu'il y a de grand dans la
personne à sa responsabilité à sa
dignité on n'a pas peur du changement on
n'a pas peur des évolutions de société
on est attaché à la protection de la
personne notre humaniste n'a rien de
conservateur c'est un humanisme de
mouvement c'est un humaniste de création
c'est un humaniste qui permet le
dépassement c'est pour ça que cet
animaliste ouvert et donc nous avons là
vraiment de quoi assumer ce que
proposait à la Juppé que nous pouvons
retrouver les uns et les autres dans
cette identité heureuse qui a un moment
fait bien sûr c'est une perspective mais
de se dire que cette humaniste là il est
fait pour nous donner de la joie de
vivre de la joie d'être ensemble et la
joie d'assumer notre dignité d'hommes
débloquer l'économie refonder la société
de valeur mais au suit reconstruire la
France puissance de paix je termine par
ce point parce que nous devons repenser
complètement notre diplomatie nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans une situation où
on a une politique étrangère éparpillée
moi je suis d'accord avec François
Fillon quand il propose le dialogue avec
Vladimir Poutine il n'y aura pas de
solution au Levant sans la Russie il n'y
aura pas de solution évidemment avec un
grand nombre de puissance et ça ne veut
pas dire qu'on s'aligne mais ça veut
dire naturellement qu'on est ce que la
politique étrangère de la France
l'indépendance l'indépendance nationale
qui permet de parler à tout le monde
c'est indépendance là qui fait qu'on est
l'ennemi une personne mais qu'on a nos
convictions qu'on a nos stratégies mais
cette conviction cette stratégie elle
est fondée sur une ambition sur un mot
un mot qu'on entend très peu hier
j'assistais on veut du président de la
République au corps diplomatique j'ai
très peu entendu le mot le mot clé de
notre politique étrangère le mot le plus
important pour nos enfants le mot auquel
nous ne devons en permanence penser
c'est le mot simple mais c'est le mot de
paix si nous voulons la puissance c'est
pour la paix c'est pas pour la guerre si
nous voulons une armée puissante si nous
voulons une dissuasion si on veut 2% du
budget pour notre défense c'est pour
être capable de protéger le peuple
français et non pas pour être des Vatan
guerre ici ola pour être capable de nous
défendre pouvoir faire peur à nos
ennemis mais parce que nous portons des
valeurs de paix et ses valeurs de paix
nous pouvons les conquérir grâce à notre
indépendance capable de nous donner la
force du dialogue c'est cette
orientation là que nous devons prendre
aujourd'hui dans le monde la France sur
tous les grands foyers de crise doit
être mobilisés avec la volonté de sa
puissance mais une puissance d'une se
veut pas belliqueuse mais qui se veut
Pacifique si je crois pour cela qu'il y
a aujourd'hui à repenser le modèle
français de politique étrangère c'est
pour ça que je trouve que dans la ligne
qui nous est proposée par François
Fillon dans ce qu'il a construit
sédimenté avec les français partout il y
a pour nous cette honneur de retrouver
les forces de la France cette honneur de
retrouver le message de la France c'est
honneur de redonner confiance et courage
aux Français nous sommes ici dans un
conseil national parce que ici
évidemment à la veille d'élection
législatives nous aimons la politique
mais n'oublions jamais que ce que nous
préférons
c'est la France
[Applaudissements]
merci cher Jean-Pierre je voudrais
je voudrais saluer Philippe Goujon
président de la Fédération de Paris je
voudrais saluer Jérôme Chartier
conseiller spécial de François Fillon je
voudrais saluer François Baroin je
voudrais saluer pierre lelouge débuté de
Paris et je voudrais saluer Florence
Berthoud que j'ai savais déjà tout à
l'heure notre maire du 5e arrondissement
de Paris et j'appelle notre président du
Sénat Gérard Larcher
[Applaudissements]
cher François Fillon mes chers amis
c'est vrai nous l'avons répété depuis ce
matin
nous nous réunissons pour la première
fois notre conseil national après des
primaires de la droite et du centre qui
furent un immense succès démocratique et
quel qui a été leur choix plus de 4300
000 électeurs ont participé à une
démarche exemplaire et moi aussi je
voudrais saluer le panache de tous les
candidats de la primaire ce panache qui
nous conduit à nous retrouver avec une
pensée particulière pour ceux qui ont
présidé notre mouvement Nicolas Sarkozy
et Alain Juppé
[Applaudissements]
avec François Fillon
ces électeurs de la droite et du centre
ont fait un choix un choix de courage un
choix de vérité si toi François qui
porte désormais leur espérance
l'espérance ne peut se réfugier dans le
mensonge au risque de provoquer la
révolte de nos concitoyens j'ai entendu
que la campagne s'annoncerait difficile
mais c'est le lot de toutes les
campagnes nous voilà depuis un mois la
cible de tous les conservatismes les
avocats du statu quo ce qui pense que
rien ne doit bouger que le clientélisme
peut faire office de projet que la
défense d'intérêt particulier peut
suffire à bâtir une ambition collective
ou qu'il faudrait faire peur mais
comment peuvent-ils ces avocats du statu
quo pensaient que ce logiciel soit
encore adapté à la situation de la
France
comment comment peuvent-ils se réfugier
dans des caricatures qui vont bon train
entre la disparition de la sécurité
sociale la taturisation de l'économie ou
ces liens avec Vladimir Poutine en
vérité quand on a ni bilan ni projet il
ne reste que le simplisme de la pensée
et la confiscation des idées nous ne
sommes dupe de rien et rien ne doit nous
détourner du rendez-vous avec les
Français car c'est de cela dont il
s'agit ce rendez-vous avec la France
c'est le tien François Pillon ça n'est
pas le nôtre c'est le tien ce dialogue
avec les Français c'est ce à quoi nous
allons t'aider à aller mais c'est ton
dialogue et je réclame ce dialogue car
pardonnez-moi c'est ça le sens profond
de l'élection
essentielle nous sommes à tes côtés plus
déterminé que jamais à livrer cette
bataille pour leur dressement de notre
pays notre famille on l'a vu ce matin et
je remercie les uns et les autres est en
ordre de marche elle réunit des
sensibilités
se rassemblement dans la diversité pour
moi une richesse mais seul notre union
totale derrière François peut nous
conduire à la victoire mais je n'ai plus
de doute
la primaire consternante elle a été
décrite la partie socialiste à bout de
souffle pris en étau entre Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et Macron nous conforte
comment peuvent-ils encore prétendre
gouverner la France le premier Mélenchon
ses poumones à vouloir incarner la
France des ouvriers celle des
travailleurs celle des insoumis mais
cette France l'a abandonné depuis bien
longtemps et souvent et trop souvent
pour rejoindre les sirènes du Front
national alors cette France d'à côté mes
chers amis à laquelle nous tenons tant
au Sénat il nous appartient à tous de la
reconquérir c'est un combat qui ne doit
pas simplement être le combat de
discours ça doit être un combat village
après village puis la vraie ville
département après département région
après région aucun territoire aucun
citoyen ne doivent plus jamais avoir le
sentiment d'être abandonné ou méprisé
alors Macron continue sa marche mais il
avait écrit l'ordre de marge de François
Hollande on connaît les conséquences
le monde change sous nos yeux nous
l'avons vu avec le brexit avec les
élections américaines les États-Unis
vont avoir leur tête dans moins de cinq
jours un président qui sans doute va
bouleverser les schémas traditionnels la
situation au Moyen-Orient est tout
particulièrement Syrie continue de se
dégrader en Israël et dans les
Territoires palestiniens d'où je reviens
les tensions sont raviver je ne peux me
résoudre à ce que seul notre pays soit
condamné à l'immobilisme elle n'exerce
plus aucune influence sur la scène
internationale alors mes chers amis que
nos soldats donnent le meilleur de leur
courage pour lutter contre le terrorisme
mes chers amis
nous avons trois mois pour nous battre
pour nous battre pour notre pays nous
avons trois mois pour tourner la page de
ce quinquennat des échecs successifs 6
millions de nos compatriotes éloignés de
l'emploi pas de croissance et la France
qui poursuit un lasablement depuis près
de 5 ans sa fuite en avant incapable de
dépenser moins incapable de produire
plus incapable de frire un véritable
premier emploi un quart de ces jeunes
incapables à moderniser son modèle
social alors François en avant on avance
sans te laisser détourner du chemin que
tu t'es tracé en avant la rencontre de
tous les Français avec le projet que tu
portes les Français sont épuisés par
trop de mensonges et de renoncement ton
programme est audacieux va tant mieux le
refus de l'obstacle trop souvent été le
mode de gouvernance
ton projet est trop libéral foutaise
l'emploi est au cœur de ton projet et le
dialogue social fait partie de ce projet
il serait trop brutal mais la vraie
brutalité c'est le chômage de longue
durée c'est l'échec de l'insertion des
jeunes c'est près de 9 millions de
Français qui vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté alors nous sommes rassemblés
autour de toi François pour la victoire
pour la République pour la France alors
mes chers amis mes chers amis du Conseil
national
dissimé tous ensemble nous prenons un
seul engagement au fait tout pour
François Fillon pour la France
chers amis je vous propose d'accueillir
François Fillon
[Applaudissements]
mes chers amis
quel plaisir de vous voir tous
rassembler
et permettez-moi de commencer en
remerciant Luc Chatel et Bernard
accueilli et tous ceux qui ont organisé
ce conseil national
comme tous ceux qui se sont exprimés
avant moi et qui ont affirmé notre
volonté d'unité de rassemblement pour
remettre la France en marche
c'est un bonheur pour moi ce matin de me
retrouver dans ma famille
au milieu des républicains
candidat à la présidence de la
République je ne suis plus l'homme d'un
parti mais je n'oublie pas d'où je viens
et surtout je ne vous oublie pas je sais
que vous serez en première ligne je sais
que c'est sur le terrain avec les cadres
et avec les militants des républicains
que la victoire au présidentielle et aux
élections législatives va nous permettre
de gagner pour redresser notre pays
[Applaudissements]
je suis fier de notre partie
je suis fier de notre parti qui a su
démontrer aux Français sa capacité à
organiser une primaire vraiment
démocratique et je veux en remercier
toutes celles et tous ceux qui en ont
été les artisans et au premier rang
d'entre eux Thierry solaire
notre primaire a été digne elle a été
digne de vous
elle a été digne des militants elle a
été digne de nos concitoyens qui
attendent le meilleur de leur
responsables politiques
certes la compétition était là mais il y
avait du respect
il y avait de l'estime entre nous tous
et je veux à ce moment
saluer notre ancien président Nicolas
Sarkozy
le remercier pour son soutien et pour ce
qu'il a fait pour notre partie
salut et remercier Alain Juppé Bruno Le
Maire Nathalie Kosciusko-Morizet
Jean-Frédéric Poisson et Jean-François
Copé
j'ai emporté la partie
le score a été franc et sans appel mais
personne n'a perdu
parce que au-delà de nos personnes c'est
notre démocratie qui a été victorieuse
et c'est une nouvelle image de la droite
qui s'est imposée aux yeux des Français
avec 4 millions d'électeurs on a mis la
barre très haut
alors on va voir si le Parti socialiste
jamais avare de leçon démocratique et
toujours prompt à se présenter en partie
du peuple est capable de faire aussi
bien
quant au Front national pas de primaire
la démocratie y est remplacée par la
généalogie et les querelles familiales
[Applaudissements]
après ma victoire je me suis attelé au
rassemblement de toutes les forces et de
toutes les sensibilités de ma famille
politique j'ai tendu la main à tout le
monde et tout le monde l'a saisi
vous allez être les faire de lance de ma
campagne j'aurais besoin de chacune et
de chacun d'entre vous alors pas de
calcul pas de dispersion pas d'ego je
n'ai qu'un mot d'ordre unité et
engagement total pour la victoire
laissez
laissez les scénarios au scénariste
laissez les sondages au sondeur
ne nous laissons ni enivrer par les
bonnes nouvelles ni abattre par les
moins bonnes une campagne présidentielle
ça réclame d'abord du sang-froid et de
l'ardeur
et la victoire viendra récompenser le
camp qui aura montré la plus grande
détermination alors le CDA aucune
intimidation on vous accuse de vouloir
redresser la France avec énergie assumer
et riposter parce que c'est nous qui
avons raison de penser que la situation
réclame du courage
on nous accuse de défendre les valeurs
françaises assumer et riposter parce que
nous n'avons pas à nous excuser d'être
patriotes d'être de droite et d'avoir du
bon sens
[Applaudissements]
je ne vais pas changer ce que je crois
et ce que je veux en fonction des
vapeurs des uns et des injonctions du
microcosme
il y a deux mois je n'étais pas son
candidat favori et bien je n'ai pas
l'intention de le devenir
ça n'est pas
ça n'est pas de l'obstination
c'est tout simplement que j'ai mes
convictions
et que j'ai la certitude que mon projet
peut redresser notre pays alors ce
projet je vais l'expliquer je vais le
préciser je vais l'enrichir de vos
meilleures idées mais pas de zigzag pas
de camomille je m'appelle François
Fillon pas François Hollande
[Applaudissements]
pour moi la démocratie ça n'est pas des
convictions pour les primaires
d'autres convictions pour la
présidentielle
et pourquoi pas
d'autres convictions enfin pour les
législatives avec 6 millions de Français
à Pôle emploi avec cette croissance
maigrelette qui ne stoppera pas la
précarisation du pays avec 2200
milliards de dettes avec les extrémistes
qui fondent vers le pouvoir avec
l'Europe qui se traîne et face à la
menace du totalitarisme islamique moi je
ne vois pas l'élection de 2017 comme
celle d'une alternance classique
non elle doit être le point de départ
d'un peuple qui part tous ces instincts
de vie se met à l'offensive et se met à
l'action nous n'avons pas d'autre choix
que d'aller à fond nous n'avons pas
d'autre choix
que d'oser le maximum
mes adversaires pensent que les Français
n'aspirent qu'à conserver le peu qu'ils
ont c'est la théorie du partage des
miettes je pense le contraire
je pense que les Français sont prêts à
s'engager pour plus qu'ils n'ont et en
cela mon projet est pour eux
l'opportunité de secouer ce système
qu'il est bride et qui les appauvris
avec vous je me bats pour redresser
notre pays
et pour lui donner un avenir pas pour
ruser avec lui et pour passer entre les
gouttes
je me bats pour le progrès économique et
social
le progrès c'est toujours une dispute
sur nous-mêmes avec nos conservatifs
avec nos égoïsmes avec nos peurs
personne ne va nous faire de cadeaux
ni le nouveau président américain
ni celui de la Chine
n'avez pas d'une soudaine croissance
internationale qui viendrait nous tirer
d'affaire
de nous dépendre notre avenir et celui
de nos enfants
évidemment nous pourrions comme la
gauche
mettre en sourdine la vérité
nous pourrions mettre l'intérêt national
de côté
nous pourrions mettre de l'eau dans
notre vin
mais ce serait de la lâcheté
et vous n'êtes pas là
et ce serait au surplus ne pas avoir
compris la colère qui gronde
les Français en ont plus cassé des
demi-mesures
quant à nos électeurs
ce qui forment le cœur de la droite
ils veulent un cap
ils veulent des choix clairs
ils veulent la liberté l'autorité la
fierté nationale c'est leur message et
c'est le mien
alors certes la force et la franchise de
mon projet m'expose au blâme
et au caricatures de ceux qui sont en
réalité mot et flous
les balssifs de partout
visiblement je gêne et on cherche à vous
intimider
lors de leur premier débat télévisé les
socialistes ont plus prononcé mon nom
que celui de la France
tous contre Fillon
tous contre la droite tous contre ces
pauvres électeurs de la primaire qui
nous respectons à l'envie ne représente
que 4 millions de Français
mais il ne suffit pas d'être contre
encore faut-il avoir quelque chose à
dire
quand il a dit
la proposer aux Français ce qui nous
mitraille
quand il a dit à ceux qui nous
caricaturent et qui n'aime la droite que
lorsqu'elle marche à l'ombre rien de
nouveau rien de sérieux pour répondre à
l'urgence d'un pays qui décroche
le déclin est là la colère monte mais
ces gens-là vous disent qu'il faut rien
changer
contre le redressement national mes
adversaires ont rédigé leur tract 100 et
larmes
purge cas social et pourquoi pas
l'Apocalypse
il m'arrive d'entendre certains à droite
utiliser les mêmes mots que la gauche
que ma victoire ait pu décevoir certains
je puis le concevoir
mais j'attends de mon parti de la
responsabilité et de la discipline
[Applaudissements]
la casse sociale elle est là
elle est sous nos yeux la casse sociale
elle truffe le bilan de François
Hollande et de ses anciens ministres qui
nous donnent aujourd'hui des leçons
je vaincrais leurs mensonge je vaincrais
ce qui prétendrait enchanté la France en
lui jouant un air de pipeau
la vérité la raison le courage seront
plus fort que les tartarinades habituels
quel que soit le vainqueur de ses
primaires oui mes amis il y aura de
toute façon une immense différence entre
nous moi je veux relancer la France moi
je veux redresser notre pays moi je veux
lui rendre ça fierté à gauche on veut
juste l'assister dans son déclin
monsieur Macron compris et Madame Le Pen
aussi
[Applaudissements]
à cette capitulation
j'oppose un chemin plus grand plus droit
un chemin exigeant mais tellement plus
engageant puisqu'il s'agit de faire de
la France une puissance gagnante la
première puissance européenne d'ici 10
ans
alors soyons passionnés
nous allons larguer les amarres
et nous allons nous détacher de cette
chape de plomb idéologique qui a piétiné
l'amour de la France qui a piétiné le
goût du travail qui a piétiné la
récompense du mérite qui a piétiné le
sens de l'autorité qui a piétiné ce
qu'il y a de plus lumineux en eau la
liberté
[Applaudissements]
j'ai j'ai appelé cela la révolution du
bon sens
je regarde l'horizon proche et je vois
ce que la France pourrait être si nous
prenons fermement les choses en main
le pays de l'audace plutôt que celui de
la bureaucratie
le pays de l'emploi plutôt que celui des
3000 pages du code du travail
le pays qui investit dans l'avenir
plutôt que d'étouffer sous la dette
le pays du dialogue social plutôt que
celui des diktates syndicaux
[Applaudissements]
le pays de la solidarité et pas celui de
l'assistanat le pays des initiatives
et pas celui des circulaires
d'une société soumise où tout est
nivelée ou tout est encadré ou tout est
figé au nom d'un misérabilisme mou nous
passerons à une société d'engagé et
d'engagement
avec tous les Français qui veulent
réussir je fonce pour une France du
plein emploi pour une France productive
c'est ma priorité absolue il faut
travailler tous pour produire plus et
pour gagner plus et il faut en parallèle
remettre nos finances publiques en ordre
parce qu'il faut mettre un terme à ce
cercle vicieux toujours plus de dépenses
toujours plus de déficit et donc
toujours plus d'impôts et toujours plus
de charges oui je baisserai massivement
les charges qui pèsent sur le coup du
travail et sur la feuille de paix ce
sera ma priorité absolue et c'est ça ma
façon de répondre aux aspirations
populaires
[Applaudissements]
je donnerai aux entreprises la liberté
de négocier le temps de travail avec
leurs salariés je reverrai notre système
éducatif je généraliserai
l'apprentissage je refondrai la
formation professionnelle je
développerai le statut de
l'auto-entrepreneur je créerai celui de
prestataire indépendant je miserai à
fond sur les technologies nouvelles et
je réformerai l'assurance chômage
[Applaudissements]
je veux
je veux plus de confiance pour ceux qui
font tourner les moteurs de l'économie
française oui je l'assume je préfère
valoriser les fortunes françaises qui
investissent en France plutôt que de
ramper devant les fortunes étrangères
la meilleure politique sociale c'est
celle qui donne du boulot à ceux qui
n'en ont pas et c'est celle qui permet à
ceux qui en ont un de progresser dans
leur carrière et dans leur salaire je
veux agir pour les jeunes qui se cassent
les dents sur la rigidité du Code du
travail je veux agir pour les chômeurs
qui préfèrent bosser le dimanche plutôt
que de pointer à Pôle Emploi le lundi je
veux agir pour les ouvriers qui
préfèrent travailler un peu plus plutôt
que de ne plus travailler du tout
[Applaudissements]
les socialistes redécouvrent les heures
supplémentaires défiscalisées qu'ils
avaient supprimé par revanche
idéologique
et certains d'entre vous se demandent
s'il ne faudrait pas revenir à ce
dispositif non et je m'en explique
notre projet repose sur l'allongement de
la durée du travail par la négociation
par la liberté donnée aux acteurs de
terrain de discuter et de décider par
eux-mêmes et pour eux-mêmes
la durée du travail dans l'entreprise
elle se définit principalement par un
critère c'est le seuil de déclenchement
des heures supplémentaires
si on réintroduit la défiscalisation des
heures supplémentaires alors l'intérêt
de négocier un allongement de la durée
du travail disparaît pour les salariés
même pour les entreprises faudra mieux
rester au 35 heures et bénéficier des
avantages fiscaux et sociaux dès la 36e
heure
enfin cette mesure se heurte à une
logique évidente la gauche a imposé les
35 heures et on y a ajouté des baisses
de charge qui coûte aujourd'hui près de
20 milliards d'euros à notre pays pour
compenser la perte de compétitivité des
entreprises franchement est-ce qu'il est
raisonnable de dépenser massivement de
l'argent public pour réduire le temps de
travail et ensuite de dépenser
massivement de l'argent public pour
l'augmenter non moi je veux qu'on en
finisse définitivement avec les 35
heures je ne serai pas le président de
la République qui reculera devant cet
obstacle
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que les Français en seront
récompensés évidemment
[Musique]
parce que lorsqu'ils travailleront plus
ils gagneront plus qu'aujourd'hui pour
réussir toutes négociation d'entreprise
avec l'accord majoritaire cherche un
compromis gagnant-gagnant
mes amis ce que je veux faire d'autres
pays de l'ont fait il s'agit pas de les
copier mais il s'agit de méditer le
résultat
il y a une dizaine d'années l'Allemagne
avait un taux de chômage supérieur au
nôtre
depuis il a été divisé par deux
grâce à une réforme courageuse de son
marché de l'emploi 4 millions d'emplois
ont été créés chez nos voisins quand le
nombre des emplois dans le secteur
marchand chez nous restait stable
par sa productivité retrouvée
l'Allemagne voit sa caisse d'assurance
chômage dégager des excédents records
alors que notre unique aligne les
déficites depuis 10 ans l'assurance
maladie allemande est-elle aussi en
excédent alors que notre sécurité
sociale a enregistré 100 milliards
d'euros de déficits outre-Rhin les
salaires ont récemment progressé de 4%
en moyenne chez nous c'est à peine mieux
que la stagnation alors mes amis ne vous
laissez pas abuser ceux qui prétendent
qu'en Allemagne c'est l'austérité et qui
défendent notre modèle économique et
social avec des très Mollo dans la voie
sur les mêmes qui qualifient mon projet
de brutal mais ce qui est brutal c'est
leur échec c'est l'échec actuel ça n'est
pas mon projet mon projet il est
responsable mon projet il est efficace
contrairement à ce que j'ai pu lire il
n'est pas réceptionniste ou
déflationniste je n'envisage pas de
faire baisser les salaires je souhaite
au contraire les débloquer par le
travail je ne milite pas pour la fin de
toute dépense publique je souhaite les
ramener de 57% du PIB à 49% en 5 ans je
ne mets pas fin à l'administration
française et à ces 5 millions 600 000
agents publics je veux en réduire le
nombre de 8% sur le quinquennat
je ne prétends pas revenir à l'équilibre
de nos comptes publics en 2018 mais en
2022 je ne stérilise pas
l'investissement puisque je vais au
contraire le stimuler par une fiscalité
plus favorable et par des privatisations
que nous affecterons au grand projet
technologiques je n'oublie pas les
Français
puisque je propose 10 milliards de
pouvoir d'achat supplémentaires pour les
salariés à travers la suppression de la
cotisation salariale maladie et à
travers une véritable politique
familiale qui retrouvera sa générosité
et son ambition
[Applaudissements]
je ne sous-estime pas les efforts de mon
plan mais il est raisonnable et il est
totalement tourné vers l'amélioration de
la vie des Français
la souffrance ne fait pas une politique
mais le renoncement pas davantage
la mécanique du déclin économique et
social de notre pays elle est connue la
montée sans fin des dépenses et des
prélèvements publics étrangle la
production privée dès lors ce sont les
importations qui répondent à la demande
au détriment de l'emploi le chômage de
masse a fait basculer des pentiers de la
population et du territoire dans la
pauvreté d'où la pression en faveur des
transforces sociaux accrus qui sont
financés dans un premier temps par la
dette mais qui appelle inévitablement de
nouveaux impôts je veux casser cette
spirale infernale je veux la casser non
pas par l'austérité et la déflation mais
par la production et la réflexion je
vais libérer l'activité de tous les
secteurs d'activités qui ont été bloqués
par le matraquage réglementaire et
fiscal l'agriculture l'industrie les
services la construction
oui nous allons effectuer une marge de
fond pour améliorer tous les facteurs de
production du travail à l'innovation en
passant par le financement et l'énergie
nous libérerons l'activité tout en
veillant non pas à la protection des
postes mais à celle des personnes
notamment par un effort d'éducation et
de formation tout au long de la vie
et cette restauration d'une production
française compétitive et bien elle
permettra de distribuer des richesses
créées au lieu d'égaliser la misère
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
le revenu moyen d'un français est
inférieur de près de 13% à celui d'un
Allemand
nos concitoyens sont étouffés par la
croissance molle par le chômage et par
les impôts et bien nous allons de
nouveau les laisser respirer
la liberté je la mêle à la France unie
et fraternelle telle que je la veux
la France unie attachée à une certaine
idée de la famille
a été dédié
et bien moi je la protégerai moi je lui
redonnerai ses droits parce que la
famille c'est l'un sinon le principal
pilier de notre société et sans la
famille nous n'avons aucune chance de
retrouver l'unité et la dynamique dont
nous avons besoin
la France unie se joue à l'école de la
République
elle doit savoir transmettre les
fondamentaux autour desquels nous devons
concentrer les efforts plutôt que de
multiplier les activités périphériques
oui nous rendons aux collectivités
locales la liberté en ce qui concerne
les rythmes scolaires
[Applaudissements]
l'école
qui doit préparer un métier
avec une valorisation massive de
l'alternance
l'école de la République
symbolisée par le port d'un uniforme
scolaire
donnant à tous les élèves quel que soit
leurs origines le goût d'être ensemble
tous égaux rassembler dans la République
française
[Applaudissements]
la France unie exige l'autorité de
l'État
l'autorité de la loi la nécessité de
l'or
mais il faut mettre des mots sur les
actes
et je veux rappeler ce que j'ai déjà dit
puisqu'il faut bien que ceux qui se
jouent des lois l'entendent 5 sur 5 un
délinquant n'est pas un mineur qui se
cherche c'est un délinquant
[Applaudissements]
un criminel n'est pas une victime c'est
un criminel
un djihadiste n'est pas un déséquilibré
c'est un terroriste
[Applaudissements]
la sécurité doit être partout et pour
tous avec des forces de l'ordre
moderniser et une justice ferme et
rapide l'impunité 0 doit être la règle
je veux rétablir les peines planchées
pour tous les récidivistes un délit une
sanction voilà la règle il doit être
parfaitement clair pour les délinquants
la France unie n'est pas une addition de
communauté et de clan elle a une
identité elle a des coutumes elle a une
culture elle a un drapeau
le repli communautariste est un danger
les 66 millions de Français ne doivent
plus être encouragés à dire et moi et
moi et moi mais entraîner à dire nous le
patriotisme c'est la seule façon de
transcender nos origines et nos
religions
[Applaudissements]
l'immigration
l'immigration sans intégration sans
assimilation doit être stoppée
dans la République française des
étrangers ont des devoirs avant de
réclamer des droits
c'est une question
c'est une question d'unité nationale
mais c'est aussi une question de
courtoisie
car quand on entre dans la maison
d'autrui on y impose pas sa loi
je veux
je veux réduire l'immigration un strict
minimum en l'organisant par Quota en
fonction de nos besoins économiques et
de nos capacités d'intégration
à ceux que nous avons choisi
d'accueillir je veux que nous disions
avec précision et fermeté ce que nous
exigeons d'eux exercer un travail
s'approprier notre langue respecter nos
règles communes
[Applaudissements]
au vrai réfugiés politiques
l'honneur commande que la France tente
sa main mais avec les glandes destins
elle doit être inflexible je veux que
nous mettions les états d'origine en
face de leur responsabilités pour qu'ils
prennent leur part de la maîtrise des
flux migratoires et qu'il s'implique
dans le retour de leur ressortissant oui
je conditionnerai l'aide au
développement à leur coopération
[Applaudissements]
l'islam radical mine nos concitoyens
musulmans il les infiltrent et il les
prend en otage
les fanatiques détestent ce que nous
sommes
je les combattrai sans relâche et sans
pitié je veux un strict contrôle
administratif du culte musulman tant que
son ancrage dans la République ne sera
pas pleinement achevé je veux la
dissolution immédiate de tous les
mouvements qui se réclament du salafiste
ou des Frères musulmans
[Applaudissements]
je veux que comme la loi française nous
y autorise on retire leur nationalité à
ceux qui sont partis nous combattre en
Syrie en Irak ou partout où ils
répondent à l'appel du Jihad
[Applaudissements]
les amis autour de nous le monde est
traversé de menace et il nous lance des
défis
évidemment pour cela il faut
un vrai président de la République
la fin de la guerre froide puis le choc
du 11 septembre
ont provoqué une déflagration du système
international et un retour fulgurant de
l'histoire
avec ses rapports de force géopolitiques
et ces crispations identitaires on ne
répondra pas à cette surchauffe en se
repliant médiocrement derrière nos
frontières
j'appelle de mes vœux une France
souveraine
appuyée par nos forces militaires dans
les moyens devront être sérieusement
augmentés
ma vision des relations internationales
est commandée par les intérêts de notre
pays et seulement par les intérêts de
notre pays
quel que soit
celui qui dirige le Kremlin à Moscou et
quel que soit celui qui dirige la Maison
Blanche à Washington l'amitié n'a rien à
faire quand on défend la place de la
France dans le monde et la sécurité des
Français
dans ce monde les dirigeants passent les
régimes évoluent mais les nations
demeure
la France n'y tiendra son rang que par
une politique d'indépendance nationale
elle doit être libre
de combattre le totalitarisme islamique
avec tous les acteurs de la région sans
aucune exclusive
libre de dire non aux États-Unis quand
ils imposent des sanctions monétaires
dans le monde
libre de parler avec la Russie avec
franchise
la souveraineté française ne peut pas
être incarnée par un homme qui navigue à
vue dans son propre pays
avec François Hollande la France a payé
le prix fort pour apprendre qu'on
n'existe pas quand on ne sait pas ce
qu'on veut et quand on ne sait pas où
l'on va
dans ce 21e siècle qui bascule vers le
continent asiatique
l'Europe doit constituer pour la France
un amplificateur de souveraineté
je ne parle pas du projet de fédération
d'Etat auquel je n'ai jamais cru
ni de l'Europe communautaire et de ses
normes byzantines je parle de l'Europe
des Nations
Unies pour défendre la civilisation
européenne et leur avenir commun
je parle d'une Europe politique
concentrée sur ses priorités
stratégiques
je parle d'une Europe appuyée sur l'euro
qui peut devenir un atout entre les
mains d'un gouvernement économique
européen je parle d'une Europe de la
sécurité partagée dans laquelle chaque
État y compris l'Allemagne devra prendre
sa part du fardeau de l'effort militaire
et de la défense
cette Europe il faut la construire
demain et il parlait d'une voix claire
voilà mes amis le sens de mon projet et
voilà l'ambition française
qui doit dicter notre unité et nos
efforts
l'ampleur et l'urgence du redressement
national nous commandera d'agir fort et
vite avec pour première priorité
l'emploi et la croissance
nous devons entendre les Français
nous devons entendre leur demande
d'honnêteté de courage et de vérité
face aux conservateurs de tout poil nous
devons aussi faire le choix de la
modernité
la société change à la vitesse de
l'électron nos enfants vont plus vite
que nous
l'autorité du Sommet sur la base ne
suffit plus à organiser une société où
les individus cherchent à décider pour
eux-mêmes et par eux-mêmes
je reviens avec beaucoup d'entre vous
des États-Unis où j'ai vu cette
modernité en marche
les entreprises françaises sont prêtes à
relever les défis du monde nouveau pour
peu qu'on leur mette pas de bâtons dans
les roues
ou des taxes sur les robots comme le
propose un socialiste certes jeunes mais
bien ancré dans le monde d'hier
[Applaudissements]
à nous d'entendre aussi les demandes de
cette société qui réclament du partage
à nous d'entendre à tous les niveaux et
pas seulement en tant que conseillère
municipale la volonté des femmes de
s'investir dans la vie publique
[Applaudissements]
nos investitures législatives sont en
cours
et en matière de parité on part de loin
et c'est vrai que nous aurons du mal à
parvenir aux
50%. mais mes amis je n'accepte pas que
nous nous donnions une image vieillotte
et misogyne la parité n'est pas une
contrainte c'est une condition
indispensable de l'unité nationale et je
vous le dis je veillerai à ce que dans
les semaines qui viennent le nombre de
femmes investies au législatives soit en
augmentation significative
[Applaudissements]
entendons aussi les Français quand ils
réclame des élus efficaces et
disponibles
entendons leurs interrogations et
parfois leur colère face à une
démocratie qu'il juge lointaine et
privilégié
l'exercice des mandats en 2017 n'obéit
plus au même règle qu'au début de la 5e
République c'est la raison pour laquelle
je ne reviendrai pas sur la loi sur le
cumul des mandats
[Applaudissements]
comment
comment nos concitoyens pourraient-ils
comprendre que nous nous occupions
d'abord de nous-mêmes au lieu de nous
occuper d'eux je vous le dis aujourd'hui
avec franchise ce serait un bien mauvais
début de mandat pour moi comme pour tous
les parlementaires de notre majorité
alors maintenant nous avons quatre mois
l'aventure va mobiliser 100% de notre
énergie il va falloir tracer à travers
les doutes à travers les vents
contraires à travers les attaques à
travers le conservatisme d'un pays qui
est en train de s'organiser pour essayer
d'en penche d'empêcher l'impensable
qu'il y est enfin à la tête de l'État un
chef du gouvernement un président de la
République une majorité parlementaire
qui soit vraiment décidé à changer les
choses pour le bien des Français pour le
plein emploi pour la puissance française
pour la liberté l'indépendance nationale
je vous entraîne dans une bataille
franche dans une bataille sans artifice
dans une bataille pour l'intérêt
national mais mes amis c'est la bataille
gagnante pour ceux qui aiment la France
et qui aime les Français vive la France
vive la république
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]